ich gebe ab nach Berlin
ja vielen Dank Claudia meine Damen und
Herren ich begrüße Sie ganz herzlich
hier aus dem Deutschen Bundestag Auftakt
der Haushaltssitzung und die Haushälter
haben wirklich sehr lange gesessen 18
Stunden über 1.000 Anträge in der
Bereinigungssitzung behandelt und es
wurde dann auch noch mal sehr viel
geändert ich kann mich kaum erinnern
dass so viel Geld hin und her geschoben
wurde bei der Neuverschuldung hat man
noch mal drauf gesattelt 31 Milliarden
und 13 Milliarden gab es für neue
Investitionen zusätzlich Christian
Lindner der Bundesfinanzminister hat
hinterher gesagt dass Ergebnis lässt
sich sehen das ist zu verstehen denn er
hat natürlich die Schuldenbremse doch
einhalten können das erste Mal seit 2009
und das Ergebnis lässt sich sehen wir
wollen mal darüber diskutieren dieses
Ergebnis erstmal zu verstehen und dafür
habe ich mir zwei Fachleute eingeladen
Otto Fricke den Haushälter der FDP und
Gesine lötschi stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzen und auch die
haushaltspolitische Sprecherin ihrer
Fraktion Herr Fricke zum Verständnis
fangen wir vorne mal an also wir haben
ja die Schuldenbremse die wird
eingehalten und
wir haben eine konjunkturelle Notlage
also wenn man die nicht hätte dann hätte
man 12,6 Milliarden aufnehmen dürfen
jetzt ist die konjunkturelle Notlage
dazu gekommen da haben Fachleute
ausgerechnet 15,3 Milliarden warum das
und dann gibt es noch
Finanztransaktionen die nicht in die
Schuldenbremse verrechnet werden wie zum
Beispiel ihre alte ihre aktienrente das
müssen wir uns jetzt noch mal erklären
also es gibt Regeln aber die sind ganz
intransparent wie ich finde eigentlich
sind sie nicht intransparent sie sind
nur komplex und wir haben es auch mit
einer komplexen Wirtschaft zu tun was
ist dahinter Gedanke die meisten die uns
jetzt zuhören sagen ja wir haben doch
eigentlich eine schwarze Null also
erstmal die schwarze Null weg nein
schwarze Null ist etwas du darfst gar
keine Schulden machen das ist ökonomisch
nicht sinnvoll das wäre wie wenn jemand
ich setze das immer ins Privatleben sagt
ich spare bis ich 65 bin und dann
schaffe ich es vielleicht mehr meine
Wohnung oder meine Haus zu kaufen das
zweite ist viele denken die
Schuldenbremse dieses statisch die sagt
einfach so hier ist die Grenze Schluss
die hat aber auch wieder bildlich
gesprochen ein Antiblockiersystem ist es
nass dann ist der Bremsweg länger das
bedeutet auch wir können etwas mehr
Verschuldung machen wenn die Wirtschaft
nicht gut läuft das ist der Grund warum
wir über die 12,5 Milliarden die der
normalvers sind rüber hinausgehen können
wäre es trocken würde die Wirtschaft gut
laufen während wir bei 12,5 oder sogar
unter 12,5 wenn die Wirtschaft gut läuft
das heißt sie atmen und passt sich an
die Wirtschaftssituation an damit in
schlechteren Zeiten mehr ausgegeben
werden kann dann gibt es noch und da
wird da kompliziert die Notsituation die
wir in den letzten Jahren haben wo wir
sie aussetzen weil es gar nicht anders
geht das haben wir jetzt in diesem
Haushalt auch wieder gesehen und das was
uns das Wirtschaftsministerium die
Sachverständigen gesagt haben wie sich
die Wirtschaft im nächsten Jahr
entwickelt erlaubt uns mehr Schulden zu
machen und der letzte Punkt ist
gleichzeitig sagt die Schuldenbremse
wenn du über einen Darlehen etwas
investierst dann darfst du das
zusätzlich im Bereich der Schuldenbremse
nutzen denn du bekommst an der Stelle
das Geld zurück und bei der aktienrente
haben wir eine Finanzierung die wenn die
akt Rente läuft dann auch wieder
zurückgezahlt wird an den Bundeshaushalt
hallo Sie sind auch schon ewig in diesem
Haus Haushaltsausschuss gerade diese
aktienrente ist ja die Idee der FDP die
kommt jetzt so hinterher gekleckert wenn
ich mir das anhöre wundere ich mich dass
andere Finanzminister nicht ihre Träume
und Ziele immer durch so ein Konstrukt
schon in den vergangenen 40 50 Jahren
haben finanzieren lassen ja ich will mal
diesen Begriff das ist glaube ich ein
kleiner Freundschaft Versprecher gewesen
Hintergedanken aufgreifen die
aktienrente ist in der Tat ganz kurz vor
der Sitzung noch mal in der sogenannten
bereinigungsvorlage durchgedrückt worden
ich hätte mich gefreut wenn wir anstatt
der aktienrente einen Prestigeprojekt
der FDP was sowieso scheitern wird wir
kennen das ja aus vergangenen
Finanzkrisen wenn man diese aktienrente
zum Beispiel endlich die
Kindergrundsicherung beschlossen hätte
aber das ist leider keine Priorität der
Bundesregierung erster Punkt zweiter
Punkt Otto Fricke hat nur sehr
ausführlich die ganzen Regeln erklärt
aber eigentlich haben können wir doch
nur eine Schlussfolgerung ziehen die
Schuldenbremse ist ökonomischer Unsinn
das sagen hier schon lange sie gehört
wirklich auf den Müllhaufen der
Geschichte müsste aus dem Grundgesetz
wieder gestrichen worden da ist sie ja
durch Abstimmung von Abgeordneten
reingekommen und es sind lauter Tricks
Taschenspieler Tricks aufgebaut worden
um diese Schuldenbremse zu umgehen ich
sage mal als Stichwort Sondervermögen
100 Milliarden extra für die Bundeswehr
jenseits der Schuldenbremse dann noch
mal ein 200 Milliarden Sondervermögen
auch jenseits der Schuldenbremse das
Problem ist nur dass irgendwann ja die
Rechnung präsentiert wird und die Frage
wer die Rechnung bezahlen soll die ist
nicht beantwortet worden und die
Sachverständigen die Otto Frick ja auch
schon gerade kurz angesprochen hatte die
Wirtschaftsweisen haben gesagt wir
brauchen jetzt eine Steuererhöhung und
zwar für die die wirklich viel Geld
haben und das ist unsere Forderung das
gut dargestellt also Holzschnitt hatte
ich noch mal die Frage warum hält man an
so einer Schuldenbremse fest wenn doch
der Steuerzahler der Bürger in
Deutschland irgendwann diese 100 und
diese 200 Milliarden und wie die
Sondervermögen alle heißen sowieso auch
zahlen muss mit Krediten und mit der
Abzahlung das ist doch eigentlich diesen
Menschen Spieler Trick wenn er auch
vielleicht öffentlich erlaubt ist aber
verstehen zu Hause wenn man zur eigenen
zum eigenen Banker ginge würde das so
nicht funktionieren jetzt und das ist
gerade das um es in einem Bild klar zu
machen das erste ist aber was wir
festhalten müssen wir haben hier eine
linke Partei sie sagt die Schuldenbremse
ist schlecht wir müssen mehr
Verschuldung machen aber nicht so rum
würde doch die CDU stehen würde die
sagen die Schuldenbremse ist gebrochen
Tatsache ist es ist genau der Mittelweg
und jetzt komme ich zu der Frage weil
ich versuche das in Bildern zu erklären
was bedeutet das für den für den Bürger
wenn der Bürger sein Girokonto anguckt
und sagt ich kann nicht über die Null
gehen oder vielleicht den kleinen Kredit
mit dem man mir einen räumt gleichzeitig
aber sagt ich investiere indem ich eine
Wohnung kaufe wo ich für einen Kredit
aufnehme und den aus meinem Girokonto
monatlich abbezahlen und genau das Bild
haben wir hier auch wir haben für zwei
Sonderfälle das eine weil wir geglaubt
haben wir haben eine Friedensdividende
weil das Objekt Reich zu Ende ist müssen
wir aber mehr tun für Verteidigung sind
wir aus unserem weit überwiegender
Mehrheit einig bis auf die linke und die
AFD glaube ich an der Stelle und auf der
anderen Seite für die Frage gashilfe
energiehilfe stromhilfe haben wir auch
gesagt müssen was tun für den Bürger
bedeutet das ich finanziere mein Haus
habe hier eine Schuld die groß ist wir
haben das Sondervermögen als Bund und
finanziere es im monatlichen im
jährlichen aus meinen täglichen
Einnahmen und Ausgaben ich habe und dazu
ist der Bund auch verpflichtet für die
Sondervermögen gibt es einen
Tilgungsplan der ab 2031 ansetzt und uns
dann hindert und da wird die
Schuldenbremse dann zeitverzögert das
ist auch so gedacht und dann hindert in
den Jahren danach neue Ideen zu haben
wie wir Geld ausgeben können alles
kompliziert die entscheidende Frage ist
ja die Frage nach den Ausgaben und den
zur Verfügung stehenden Einnahmen der
Bundesfinanzminister hat also jetzt
darauf geachtet dass er genau diese
Einnahmen in diesen Grenzen gestaltet er
hat unter anderem zum Beispiel 40
Milliarden eingerechnet der Rücklagen
dieses Staates und da sagen viele aus
der Opposition von CDU CSU zum Beispiel
das ist unklug von ihm denn dieses Geld
kann man vielleicht im Jahre 24 25
besser verwenden die diese Frage ist
glaube ich dass wir endlich unser
Steuersystem in Ordnung bringen müssen
und ich darf noch mal auf den Rat der
Wirtschaftsweisen oder
Sachverständigenrat beide Begriffe sind
ja allgemein bekannt Hinweisen sie haben
gesagt wir müssen für diese Situation
das war deren Rat die Steuern für die
wirklich sehr sehr reichen für einen
bestimmten Zeitraum erhöhen wir sagen
als Linke wir brauchen endlich eine
übergewinnsteuer denn in jeder Krise
gibt es Menschen die ärmer werden und
welche die reicher werden und in anderen
Ländern die uns wirtschaftlich
vergleichbar sind ist ja diese
übergewinnsteuer schon eingeführt worden
es ist ja nicht so dass nur die
Energiekonzerne über Gewinne machen auch
die Rüstungskonzerne machen übergewinne
und wenn wir uns anschauen wie die
Lebensmittelpreise explodiert sind das
hat ja mit der Inflation gar nichts mehr
zu tun schauen wir nach Großbritannien
z.B die Mutterland ist Kapitalismus da
gibt es eine übergewinnsteuer und was
sich jetzt die Ampel ausgedacht hat so
eine zufallsgewinnsteuer die steht ja
noch in dem Sternen die ist nicht
beschlossen worden und darum ist das
unsere ganz klare Forderung
übergewinnsteuer muss eingeführt werden
Wirtschaftsweisen ist der Stichwort die
haben ja empfohlen dass man zeitlich
besser verdienende besser zur mehr zur
Kasse bittet oder aber einen energiesoli
für besser verdienende ja man kann an
der Stelle natürlich immer das Spiel
machen dass ich sage ich nehme mehr ein
dann wird das schon funktionieren meine
Erfahrung ist bei aller
nachvollziehbaren vermeintlichen
sozialen Gerechtigkeit wenn du es
überziehst bei der Frage wie du in der
Progression rein gehst wenn wir jetzt
schon sehen wie der das obere Viertel
über 70% der Lohn und
einkommensteuereinnahmen finanziert da
musst du dir überlegen wie weit du
dagegen kannst und wenn das Beispiel
Großbritannien kommt und das als
Vergleich genommen würde ich glaube
nicht dass sie eine Lötsch gerne die
Lohn und einkommensteuerbeträge für gut
verdienende hätte wie sie in
Großbritannien sind da sind sie nämlich
niedriger man muss das Gesamtsystem
sehen und ich kann dann der Stelle nur
aus Haushälter sagen gibst du den Bund
mehr Geld oder dem Land oder der Kommune
heißt das nicht automatisch das entweder
mehr gespart wird sondern es wird
einfach mehr ausgegeben und da sage ich
dann das kann nicht der Sinn von
vernünftige Haushaltspolitik sein da bin
ich dann eben doch einer der du musst
mit dem Mitteln die du hast zu
rangekommen und muss da dann schauen was
die Frage angeht der der übergewinne
werden wir das jetzt ganz genau uns
ansehen an welcher Stelle über Gewinne
kommen denn das muss man dann ja auch
sagen das wird auch heißen die Linke
will für die Betreiber von Windrädern
die im Moment sehr viele Gewinne machen
wegen der hohen Strompreise eine
Sondersteuer haben und nicht nur für
Leute wie wie jetzt sag ich mal
Unternehmen wie RWE und andere die die
machen gleichzeitig sage ich auch immer
ich will ja gar nicht übergewinne
beschleunigen ich möchte eigentlich dass
diese Unternehmen investieren
Arbeitsplätze sichern Nachhaltigkeit
ermöglichen das wird die Aufgabe in den
nächsten Jahren sein und nicht die Frage
ist der Staat noch mehr Geld kriegt
kommt also die die Standard Beispiel ist
ja mit den äh Windkraftwerken natürlich
sind wir dafür die erneuerbaren Energien
zu stärken und was die Ampel jetzt macht
ist ja genau die Rolle rückwärts da wird
zum Beispiel Steinkohle aus Südafrika
importiert ich halt kann das mit
Nachhaltigkeit überhaupt nicht verbinden
die Frage ist natürlich gibt man wofür
gibt man Geld aus das ist doch die
entscheidende Frage und wenn wir uns
anschauen wie viel Menschen in unserem
Land arm sind wieder Zustand unserer
Schulen ist wieder Zustand von vielen
Krankenhäusern ist dass viele Kranken
ist da jetzt vor der Situation stehen
weil sie keinen Inflationsausgleich
bekommen der ausreichend ist schließen
zu müssen dann sage ich dafür brauchen
wir mehr Geld weniger Geld brauchen wir
ganz klar für die Rüstung das versandet
sowieso ja genau ich will mal auf die
Ausgaben jetzt schauen da hat der
Haushaltsausschuss noch eine Milliarde
bewilligt für Munition angeblich fehlt
der Bundeswehr Munition im Wert von 20
Milliarden Euro aber dennoch Herr Fricke
wichtig bei Ausgaben und Einnahmen ist
auch immer das was die Politiker
versprechen erzählt haben der
Bundeskanzler hat hier in diesem Hohen
Hause gesagt also zwei Prozent für die
Bundeswehr das wird nach Berechnung in
den nächsten vier Jahren überhaupt in
einem Jahr erreicht werden es sei denn
man nimmt aus dem Sonderhaushalt was
dazu aber so war das damals nicht gesagt
worden ist das nicht ein Bruch der
versprechen dieser ampelregierung also
entscheidend ist wir wollen auf Dauer in
dieser Legislatur auf diese zwei Prozent
weil wir eben nachholen müssen zweitens
die berühmten munitionssache ist eine
sogenannte Verpflichtungsermächtigung
wir ermöglichen den
Verteidigungsministerium für die
nächsten Jahre schon Verträge einzugehen
Leben in den nächsten Jahren aus dem
Sondervermögen mehr finanzielle
Möglichkeiten zu haben ja stimmt wir
haben jetzt im ersten Jahr nur acht
Milliarden statt 20 Milliarden
zusätzlich aus dem Sondervermögen aber
nach dem Motto einfach hauptsache ich
gebe das Geld aus egal was ich dafür an
Waffen bekomme wäre ziemlich blödsinnig
entscheidend wird jetzt sein in den
nächsten Jahren bleiben wir unter den 20
pro Jahr dann wäre es schlecht oder
gehen wir über die 20 und kompensieren
das so und da sage ich wenn ich neue
Flugzeuge neue Schiffe Panzer wenn ich
all das anschaffe dann will ich nicht
von heute auf morgen was haben das
gibt's nämlich nicht im Regal bei Aldi
oder sonst wo sondern es muss geschafft
werden aber das ist und da ist die
Verpflichtung dieser Koalition in dieser
Legislatur zu schaffen bei Bewaffnung
Militär kommen nicht weiter ihre
Position ist ja auch bekannt aber gucken
Sie mal auf den Haushalt gibt es da
irgendwas positives wo sie sagen das
hätten wir auch so gemacht und was fehlt
ihnen es gibt natürlich immer ein
Kleinigkeiten was positives was mir vor
allen Dingen am Herzen liegt ist die
Armut Bekämpfung und dass die
Kindergrundsicherung auf das Jahr 20 25
geschoben werden soll ist etwas was ich
überhaupt nicht akzeptieren kann und ich
werde die ganze Woche dafür Werbung
machen dass wir vielleicht zumindest bis
Freitag die Erkenntnis haben dass wir
die Kindergrundsicherung sehr sehr
schnell brauchen denn für unser Land
zerstört es auch die Zukunft wenn Kinder
in schlechten Situationen aufwachsen das
können wir nicht akzeptieren und ganz
kurz noch eine Frage an Herrn Fricke ihr
Parteifreund und Wolfgang Kubicki macht
sich heute Sorgen um den Fortbestand der
ampelregierung bzw um die Existenz der
FDP weil man immer nur nachgibt den
Sozialdemokraten und den Grünen so
ähnliches formuliert unter anderem
finanziert man also ein
Flüchtlingsschiff neuerdings was
überhaupt nicht Interesse der Europäer
sei so Kubicki wackelt hier die Ampel
nein ich sehe das nicht ich kann nur
sagen wir haben als Haushälter sehr gut
gehandelt und ich hätte sonst als
Kronzeugen zu der Frage ob die FDP sich
wenig durchsetzen kann immer Gesine
lötscht sich wirklich durch also das
zweite bei dem Schiff ist hier haben wir
als Haushaltsausschuss im Rahmen eines
kompromissystem auswärtigen Amt die
Möglichkeit gegeben zwei Millionen an
eine Organisation zu geben aber unter
den Voraussetzungen dessen was im
Haushalt steht das auswärtige wird das
hier ordentlich Regeln und das sage ich
dann aber auch bei der Frage ob Menschen
im Mittelmeer sterben oder nicht werden
sie von mir als Liberalen nicht hören
dass mir das egal ist Frau Lötsch als
Kronzeugen vielen Dank dass sie da waren
vielen Dank Herr Fricke ja meine Damen
und Herren das wird hier eine muntere
haushaltswoche werden ich gebe jetzt
rein zunächst geht es um den Gesamtetat
und wir erwarten auch dass der
Bundesfinanzminister das Wort ergreift
[Musik]
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich wünsche Ihnen allen
einen schönen guten Morgen die Sitzung
ist eröffnet
für die heutige 68 Sitzung sowie die
weiteren Sitzung in dieser Woche
konnte zwischen den Fraktionen keine
Tagesordnung vereinbart werden die
Fraktion der AFD hat den Vorschlag der
anderen Fraktion widersprochen ich habe
daher dem Bundestag mit der
vorgeschlagenen Tagesordnung einberufen
nach
§ 21 Absatz 3 der Geschäftsordnung ist
für die Genehmigung der Tagesordnung ein
plenarbeschluss erforderlich
interfraktionell ist vereinbart worden
die noch zu beschließende Tagesordnung
um die in der
zusatzpunkteliste aufgeführten ohne
debattepunkte zu erweitern außerdem
mache ich auf zwei nachträgliche
Überweisung im Anhang zur Zusatzpunkte
aufmerksam
die Fraktion SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP wünschen weiterhin aufsetzung
und zwar der zweiten und dritten
Beratung
des von den Fraktionen der spd-bündnis
90 die Grünen und FDP eingebrachten
Entwurfs eines zweiten Gesetzes zur
Änderung des
energiesicherungsgesetzes und anderer
energiewirtschaftlicher Vorschriften auf
Drucksache 4.328
der zweiten und dritten Beratung des von
der Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Entwurfs eines fünften Gesetzes zur
Änderung des Bundesfernstraßen
mautgesetzes auf Drucksachen
3.171 und 4476
sowie der ersten Beratung des von den
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP eingebrachten Entwurf eines Gesetzes
zur Zahlung einer einmaligen
energiepreispauschale für Studierende
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler sowie
berufsfachschülerinnen und
Berufsfachschüler in Bildungsgängen mit
den Ziel eines mindestens zweijährigen
berufsqualifizierenden Abschlusses auf
Drucksache
4.536 die Beratung soll am Donnerstag
nach den ohne debattenpunkten mit einer
debattendorf von jeweils 26 Minuten
erfolgen die Fraktion der AFD beantrag
darüber hinaus eine Aussprache zu
Einzelplan 02 deutscher Bundestag
dazu wird soweit mir bekannt ist das
Wort gewünscht
und das Wort hat zuerst für die
SPD-Fraktion Katja Mast
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
leider konnten wir interfraktionell das
heißt zwischen den Fraktionen nicht die
Erweiterung der Tagesordnung um das
Gesetz Änderung des
bundesfernstraßen-mautgesetzes
verständigen dass wir das diese Woche im
Deutschen Bundestag diskutieren und
abschließen
grundsätzlich ist es so mit Blick auf
die parlamentarischen beratungsabläufe
konnten wir das in der letzten
Sitzungswoche nicht machen weil erst
eine Sondersitzung des
Verkehrsausschusses am Freitag in der
letzten Sitzungswoche überhaupt erst
ermöglicht hat dass wir dieses Gesetz
auf die Tagesordnung setzen deswegen
müssen wir die parlamentarischen
Beratungen im Bundestag in dieser Woche
abschließen um den Bundesrat der muss
dem Gesetz nämlich zustimmen diesen
Freitag zu erreichen am 25
November und warum ist es zwingend
notwendig weil wenn wir das nicht diese
Woche beschließen
nehmen wir im nächsten Jahr weniger Maut
ein und können deshalb weniger Geld in
die Infrastruktur investieren und jetzt
wird man normalerweise ja denken macht
nichts dann macht man es einen Monat
später das ist aber in diesem Gesetz
nicht der Fall sondern es würde sich um
12 Monate verschieben aufgrund der
technischen Bedingungen und deshalb
wissen wir zwar dass es gute
geflogenheit ist in haushaltswochen des
Deutschen Bundestags nur in begründeten
Ausnahmefällen
Gesetzesberatungen aufzusetzen
zusätzliche Gesetzesberatung ist ja auch
ein Gesetz der Bundeshaushalt
finden aber dass es sowohl beim
mautgesetz
um mehr Geld für die Investitionen
Infrastruktur zu haben beim Energie-
und um die 200
energiepreispauschale für Studierenden
Auszubildende zu bekommen noch dieses
Jahr das aufzusetzen die Opposition hat
dem nicht zugestimmt hat aber gewünscht
wenn wir aufsetzen dass wir das nicht
ohne Debatte sondern mit Debatte machen
und deshalb schlagen wir vor jeweils 26
Minuten Debatten als
ampelfraktionen und als Ampel Koalition
das ist der eine Punkt um den es hier
geht der zweite Punkt ist dass die AFD
beantragt
dass der
Einzelplan 02 das ist der Haushalt des
Deutschen Bundestags
nicht wie üblich ohne Debatte
verabschiedet wird sondern mit Debatte
das ist ein ganz besonderer Punkt weil
es üblich ist dass wir die Haushalte der
anderen Verfassungsorgane des
Bundesrates des
Bundespräsidialamts des Deutschen
Bundestags als Institution ohne Debatte
verabschieden im Bundestag und das immer
in der Regel einmütig im
Haushaltsausschuss so verabschiedet wird
und warum möchte die AFD des
ausgerechnet beim Haushalt des
Bundestages nicht erreichen weil sie
gut begründete und sachlich gebotene
Ausgaben
skandalisieren will um ein
parteipolitisches Süppchen zu kochen
ihre Debattenbeiträge in der
Vergangenheit im Bundestag zeigen sie
wollen überall dort kürzen oder gar die
Ausgaben auf Null setzen wo es um die
Stärkung unserer Demokratie um die
Menschenrechte und um den Ethikrat geht
und genau deshalb weil das ein
durchschaubares Spiel ist werden wir
Ihren Antrag ablehnen und zugleich bitte
ich Sie darum
dem Antrag der ampelkoalitionen auf
zusätzliche aufsetzung aller drei
Gesetzentwürfe insbesondere des
mautgesetzes heute zuzustimmen und damit
den Weg frei zu machen dass wir die
Debatten im Deutschen Bundestag führen
können und dieses Gesetz abschließen
können bevor der Bundesrat sich am
Freitag trifft vielen Dank
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Thorsten frei
Thorsten Frey auch erst
parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer hier
zu der Geschäftsordnungsdebatte im
Deutschen Bundestag
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben es
heute morgen mit zwei
geschäftsordnungsanträgen zu tun zum
einen von der Koalition und zum anderen
von der AFD
beim afd-antrag kann ich es kurz machen
wir werden Ihnen ablehnen weil es den
guten parlamentarischen Gepflogenheiten
entspricht dass wir hier im Deutschen
Bundestag die Einzelpläne von
Bundespräsident Bundesrat und Bundestag
nicht im Einzelnen debattieren das
gebietet aus meiner Sicht auch der
Respekt zwischen den Verfassungsorganen
und deshalb ist es eine gute Übung die
wir auch dieses Mal sofort setzen
möchten wenn ich bei den guten
parlamentarischen Gepflogenheiten bin
beim guten parlamentarischen brauch dann
bin ich auch ganz schnell beim
Geschäftsordnungsantrag der
Koalitionsfraktionen denn es entspricht
eben auch dem guten parlamentarischen
Brauch dass man die Haushaltsdebatten
hier im Deutschen Bundestag wo es also
um das Königsrecht des Parlaments geht
nicht mit
haushaltsfremden sachdebatten zusätzlich
belastet das hat gute Gründe wir
diskutieren hier über einen Haushalt der
fast eine halbe Billion Euro umfasst und
darauf wollen wir und darauf müssen wir
uns fokussieren und konzentrieren im
übrigen bei diesem parlamentarischen
brauch wenn man so will da hält sich die
Opposition dran es gibt keine
Fragestunde es gibt keine
regierungsbefragung es gibt keine
aktuelle Stunde aber die
Koalitionsfraktionen die Scheren sich da
nicht drum in einer wie wir es hier
schon häufiger erlebt haben großen
Arroganz und deswegen
will ich da sehr differenziert
argumentieren und ihnen sagen
Frau Kollegin Mast hat es ja auch mit
der Eilbedürftigkeit hier begründet ja
wir sind keine
regierungstragende aber wir sind eine
staatstragende Fraktion und überall dort
wo die Dinge zu tun haben mit Krieg mit
Krise mit den Herausforderungen dieser
Zeit wo wir auch anerkennen unter
welchen Belastungen die Regierung steht
da unterstützen wir Sie
selbstverständlich und deswegen haben
wir auch die Trennung der Abstimmung
darüber verlangt weil wir der aufsetzung
des energiesicherungsgesetzes zustimmen
werden wir halten es zwar in der Sache
nicht für überzeugend aber es ist
natürlich in der Not der Situation
geboten darüber zu diskutieren und
deswegen machen wir das auch in der
haushaltswoche und ich will auf das
zweite Gesetz eingehen bei dem wir
ebenfalls zu
ebenfalls einverstanden sind dass das
diese Woche beraten wird da geht es um
die Einmalzahlung für Studentinnen und
Studenten und Fachschüler
ja wir haben Sie aufgefordert dass sie
das machen in der vorletzten
Sitzungswoche mit einem eigenen Antrag
sie haben die Studenten genauso
vergessen wie die Rentner bei den bei
dem entsprechenden Entlastungspaket und
dann haben sie Anfang September
versprochen dass sie auch für die
Studenten eine Entlastung schaffen jetzt
11 Wochen später legen sie in der ersten
Lesung einen Gesetzentwurf vor der Null
Klarheit verschafft ein echter
rohrkrippierer bis jetzt und da muss man
doch wirklich fragen was ist denn das
für ein Zeitdruck wenn sie elf Wochen
brauchen um einen Gesetzentwurf
vorzulegen der noch nicht einmal die
Fragen beantwortet die sich in diesem
Zusammenhang stellen
aber weil es in der Sache wichtig und
notwendig ist das sehen wir jedenfalls
auch so sind wir damit einverstanden und
dann komme ich zum dritten Punkt da wird
es wirklich absurd beim Fernstraßen
mautgesetz
beim Fernstraßen mautgesetz nicht nur
dass wir das inhaltlich ablehnen aber
jetzt müssen sie sich mal eines vor
Augen halten den Kabinettsbeschluss zu
diesem Gesetz hat die Bundesregierung im
Mai
getroffen und bereits am 22 September
war die erste Lesung hier im Deutschen
Bundestag und sie wollen Ihr uns allen
Ernstes weismachen dass es Zeitnot und
Zeitdruck wäre der sie veranlasst jetzt
den Bundesrat am Freitag erreichen zu
müssen und deshalb diese Woche hier
abzustimmen wenn ich kann Ihnen sagen
woran das liegt dieser Zeitdruck der
kommt nicht von außen dieser Zeitdruck
kommt von ihnen sie sind nicht nur
respektlos gegenüber dem Parlament
sondern sie haben vor allen Dingen nicht
die handwerklichen Fähigkeiten ein
Gesetz auch in angemessener Zeit so
fertig zu machen dass man das hier im
Bundestag auch zur Abstimmung stellen
kann und deswegen sage ich Ihnen ganz
klar wir unterstützen Sie überall da wo
unser Land in dieser Not und Gefahr ist
hier unterstützen sie aber nicht darin
wenn sie es nicht schaffen ihre Aufgaben
ordentlich zu erledigen und genau so ist
es ich will sie einfach nur daran
erinnern sie sind angetreten mit dem
Ziel den Bundestag wieder zu einem Ort
der Debatte zu machen das Gegenteil
davon ist der Fall sie wollten diese
Punkte auch noch ohne Debatte hier
diskutieren nicht diskutieren sondern
zur Abstimmung stellen das ist wirklich
eine Respektlosigkeit vor dem Bundestag
besonders gleichen und deswegen werden
wir letzteres ablehnen vielen Dank
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Doktor Irene
mihalic
und auch sie ist die parlamentarische
Geschäftsführerin ihrer Fraktion die
Parlamentarischen Geschäftsführer führen
in der Regel ja so eine Geschäftsordnung
Debatte
wir haben natürlich völlig Recht in
einer Sache dass hier ist eine
haushaltswoche und es ist guter
parlamentarischer brauch haushaltswochen
nicht mit haushaltsfremden sagt Debatten
in irgendeiner Art und Weise zu
überfrachten aber gestatten Sie mir
erstens den Hinweis als wir noch in der
Opposition waren ist es auch in Zeiten
der großen Koalition also als sie diese
Regierung hier geführt haben auch
passiert dass wir ein haushaltswochen
auch mal über andere Dinge beraten
mussten und zwar immer dann und zwar
immer dann wenn es um außergewöhnliche
Dinge ging oder wenn es aus zeitlichen
Gründen in irgendeiner Art und Weise
erforderlich war und genau das ist doch
hier jetzt auch der Fall wenn wir das
mautgesetz nicht auf die Tagesordnung
setzen könnten dann könnte der Bundesrat
nicht rechtzeitig darüber befinden und
dann könnte das Gesetz wie meine
Kollegin Katja Mass schon zutreffend
dargestellt hat eben nicht zum ersten
Januar in Kraft treten und deswegen ist
es von großer Bedeutung dass wir dieses
Gesetz auch in dieser Woche hier im
Deutschen Bundestag abschließen meine
Damen und Herren
jetzt beklagen sie jetzt beklagen sie
dass es an handwerklichen Mengen liegt
oder daran dass etwa hier diese
Ampelkoalition nicht schnell genug
arbeiten würde also Herr frei das weiß
ich hier aufs aller schärfste zurück ich
glaube keine Bundesregierung zuvor und
auch kein Deutscher Bundestag zuvor war
mit einer so großen Zahl an Krisen und
Problemen konfrontiert wie wir hier alle
gemeinsam im Parlament und auch in der
Bundesregierung und wir leben in diesem
besonderen Zeiten und wir versuchen
alles dafür zu tun unsere Gesetze hier
so durchs Parlament zu bringen dass sie
die Menschen von den schwerwiegenden
Problemen mit denen wir alle zu kämpfen
haben wirksam entlasten und da gehen sie
ja auch bei zwei Punkten mit sie haben
gerade gesagt da wo Krise ist da
unterstützen sie uns ja auch als
Koalition inhaltlich und tragen das mit
nur bei der Maut da sind sie eben nicht
der Meinung das so machen zu müssen weil
sie inhaltlich dagegen sind ja dann
geben Sie doch wenigstens zu dass das
eigentlich der Grund ist weswegen sie
das laut Gesetz heute nicht auf
Tagesordnung geben wollen ja ihm geht es
hier nicht um Verfahrensfragen sondern
weil sie es inhaltlich ablehnen und
deswegen tragen Sie es mit nicht mit so
ehrlich könnten Sie an dieser Stelle
einmal sein
sie haben gerade gesagt sie sind keine
regierungstragende Fraktion da kann ich
nur sagen zum Glück sie sind
eine staatstragende Fraktion ja das
würde ich gerne mal sehen und zwar an
der Stelle wo sie behaupten sie würden
uns in diesen krisenhaften Zeiten hier
unterstützen wenn wir hier mit Hochdruck
im Deutschen Bundestag die Gesetze
verabschieden sie zu Bewältigung der
multiplen Krisen mit denen wir alle
gemeinsam konfrontiert sind
die erforderlich sind um diese Krisen zu
bewältigen dann bedingt es nun mal dass
auch manche andere Gesetzesvorhaben die
vielleicht nicht unmittelbar etwas mit
der Krisenbewältigung zu tun haben in
einen zeitlichen Verzug geraten oder
eine längere Beratungsdauer in Anspruch
nehmen das heißt wenn Sie unserem
Geschäftsordnungsantrag zustimmen dann
tun sie auch gleichzeitig etwas für die
Krisenbewältigung in unserem Land auch
mit Blick auf das mautgesetz nämlich in
der Ampel sondern insgesamt in unserem
Land und deswegen werbe ich noch einmal
oder appellieren noch mal an Sie als
staatstragende Fraktion unserem
Geschäftsordnungsantrag zur aufsetzung
dieser Gesetze zuzustimmen ganz
herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion DR
Bernd Baumann
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
den Bundeshaushalt aufzustellen ist das
Königsrecht des Parlamentes es geht
darum zu bestimmen wofür der Staat das
Geld seiner Bürger ausgibt im kommenden
Jahr über 500 Milliarden und mit den
nebenhaushalten noch viel mehr dafür ist
die haushaltswoche da diese konzentriert
sich ausschließlich auf die Themen des
Haushalts in ihr werden die vielen
einzeletas kritisch debattiert und
abgestimmt das ist Konsens in diesem
Parlament trotzdem kommt jetzt die Links
gelbe Regierung und will gleich drei
Gesetzesvorhaben hier diskutieren die
mit dem Haushalt nichts zu tun haben nur
weil sie hier mit ihrer Regierungsarbeit
aus Inkompetenz nicht rechtzeitig fertig
geworden sind meine Damen und Herren das
geht so nicht wir leben den Antrag der
Regierung ab
aber liebe Kollegen von der CDU warum
nehmen Sie hier den Bund so voll sie
haben doch vor kurzem noch selbst an der
Regierung genauso unprofessionell
gearbeitet sie sind doch auch nicht
fertig geworden sie haben die
haushaltswochen ebenso missachtet und
noch schnell Gesetze reingeschoben die
viel zu spät fertig geworden sind sie
haben genauso schlecht gearbeitet meine
Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
ich möchte jetzt aber im Rahmen dieser
Debatte noch ein anderes Thema
ansprechen dass unseres Erachtens noch
dringender noch bedeutsamer noch
unglaublicher ist meine Damen und Herren
wir müssen unsere
Staatsorgane vor parteipolitischen
Missbrauch schützen deshalb müssen wir
heute hier den einzelnen 02 des
Bundestages debattieren denn dieser
enthält Millionenausgaben
die gegen die parteipolitische
Neutralität unserer Staatsorgane
verstoßen die sie unterwandern sie
parteipolitisch instrumentalisieren
deswegen müssen wir den Detail hier
offen diskutieren und debattieren wir
dürfen ihn nicht einfach durchwinken wie
sie alle sich das hier gedacht haben das
darf nicht sein
[Applaus]
im Rahmen dieser kurzen
Geschäftsordnungsdebatte nur ein kleines
Beispiel ein typisches der Bundestag
finanziert ein sogenanntes
deutsches Institut für Menschenrechte
was macht dieses Institut
konzentriert es sich auf die
internationale Lage der Menschenrechte
nein es veröffentlicht Studien über die
AFD schauen wir mal in eine dieser
angeblich wissenschaftlichen Studien
schauen wir mal rein während alle
führende migrations- und kulturforscher
davon ausgehen dass die Kulturen
verschiedener Weltregionen sich
selbstverständlich unterscheiden und
kulturelle Differenzen auch
Schwierigkeiten bereiten bei der
Integration und der Migration kommt
dieses Institut zu einem ganz anderen
Ergebnis wer solche Kulturunterschiede
auch nur benennt sei ich zitiere
rassistisch und rechtsextremistisch wer
für unser Land eine Leitkultur Herr März
wer für unser unintelligible eine
Leitkultur fordert wie sie und die CDU
der sei rassistisch und
rechtsextremistisch meine Damen und
Herren mit Wissenschaft hat das gar
nichts zu tun das ist reine linke
Propaganda finanziert mit Mitteln des
Bundestages das muss sie auf die
Tagesordnung
denn es kommt ja noch schlimmer das
Institut daran bitte ich habe das jetzt
ein bisschen laufen lassen weil sie
einen Antrag natürlich begründen müssen
aber sie gehen jetzt schon sehr weit in
den Inhalt dieses Institutes und wir
haben hier eine Geschäftsordnung Debatte
das Inhalt der Inhalt dieses Institutes
ist der Grund warum es hier diskutieren
müssen ich muss das kurz ausführen das
muss auf die Tagesordnung denn es kommt
noch schlimmer ich rede nicht weniger zu
Geschäft sondern alle meine Vorredner
das möchte ich immer deutlich sagen
das Institut behauptet in seinen
Gutachten die AFD fordere aktiv zur
Gewalt auf sie wolle sogar allen Ernstes
ihre politischen Gegner ermorden auf
Seite 22 behauptet der sogenannte
Gutachten die AFD rufe über
bundestagspolitiker ich zitiere wörtlich
und politischen Mord auf Herr Baumann
Fehler zeigen
bitte stattdessen einfach weiß auf linke
Propaganda Broschüren und wir reagieren
sie alle hier auf dieses Machwerk
sie bedanken sich sie erhöhen doch das
Budget dieses pseudo-instituts und 40
Prozent so gut gefällt Ihnen das weil es
gegen die AFD geht mit allen Mitteln
auch mit den schmutzigsten deshalb
wollen sie sie auch nicht offen
debattieren meine Damen und Herren
der Respekt vor dem Verfassungsorgan
Bundestag gebietet es dass man
Fehlentwicklung offen anspricht nicht
damit dass man sie totschweig meine
Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Johannes Vogel
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir verbringen mit dieser
Geschäftsordnungsdebatte eher zu viel
Zeit deswegen mache ich ganz kurz drei
Bemerkungen erstens ist meine ich sehr
ernst ich habe großen Respekt vor allen
Parlamentariern Koalition aber
insbesondere auch Opposition mit welchem
auch auch vor dir lieber Matthias
Burgwald mit
welchem Tempo welcher Tiefe und welchem
Arbeitsethos hier in dieser kriegs- und
Krisenlage in der wir uns in Europa seit
Monaten befinden mit hochdruckgesetzes
Arbeit gemacht wird denn das ist nicht
nur Aufgabe der Regierung sondern das
ist insbesondere Aufgabe des Parlaments
großen Respekt davor vor diesem
Hintergrund jetzt hier zur
problematisieren dann ein Gesetz mal
etwas länger dauert finde ich dann aber
doch ein wenig kleinteilig und damit
sollten wir uns in meinen Augen nicht zu
lange aufhalten ja es ist richtig dass
wir im Ältestenrat vereinbart haben dass
nur die Themen ausnahmsweise in einer
haushaltswoche beraten werden die ent
ein ganz konkreten Bezug zur krieg- und
Krise haben oder wo es zeitkritisch ist
mit Blick auf dem Bundesrat am nächsten
Freitag und natürlich ist es beim Thema
mauzeit kritisch denn wenn wir das
mautgesetz nicht diese Woche beraten
dann kommt entweder die Maut nicht dann
entgehen den Bundeshaushalt übrigens
eingeplante Einnahmen deswegen hat das
natürlich auch mit den
Haushaltsberatungen diese Woche zu tun
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von CDU
und CSU
oder
oder die Maut entsteht wird
vorangetrieben von den Betreibern in
einem Status der Rechtsunsicherheit und
beim Thema Maut
ausgerechnet beim Thema Maut erneut
Rechtsunsicherheiten zuzulassen das
würde ich uns dringend nicht raten und
lieber
hochverehrter geschätzter Kollege
Thorsten frei nach dem Maut Horror der
CSU hier von Handwerk der Koalition
ausgerechnet beim Thema Maut
handwerkliche Fähigkeiten abzusprechen
das hat schon Putzke das hat schon
in diesem Sinne bitte stimmen Sie die
Geschäftsordnungsantrag der Koalition zu
vielen Dank
so fehlt noch eine Fraktion bisher waren
es die ersten Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer die hier gesprochen
haben und jetzt redet Alexander Ulrich
der erste parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer Jan Cortes erkrankt gute
Besserung von dieser Stelle
ja von der FDP wenn man will kann man
jedes Gesetz mit Haushalten Verbindung
bringen denn nahezu jedes Gesetz hat
irgendwelche haushaltsauswirkungen
deshalb wird eine Koalition immer Gründe
finden warum man in einer haushaltswoche
das aufsetzen will das ist aber keine
Begründung die glaube ich stichhaltig
ist genauso wenig sage ich auch an die
an die Rednerin der Grünen man kann
nicht schlechtes regieren immer nur
hinter den Krisen dieses dieser Welt
verstecken denn diese Bundesregierung
hat dieses Land bisher schlecht auf
diesen kommenden Winter vorbereitet es
wurden im Sommer viele Wochen und Monate
eigentlich verschwendet mit einer
gasumlage Debatte anstatt das Land
Gesetzgeber nicht so vorzubereiten dass
man nicht Angst hat vor den nächsten Gas
oder strompreisrechnung
und Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben letztes
Jahr Wahlkampf gemacht mit dem Wort
Respekt es war am Sommer respektlos dass
sie die Rentnerinnen und Rentner und
Studierenden nicht gleich mit dem
Gesetzgebung mit reingenommen haben wie
wir es als Linke gefordert haben das
hätte viele Peinlichkeiten wären
verhinderbar gewesen und dass sie jetzt
das jetzt nachholen kostet ja auch viel
Geld
denn jetzt kommst du doppelt Bezahlung
die neue Ungerechtigkeiten auslösen das
wäre vermeidbar gewesen aber sie wollten
ja ganz bewusst sie sind nicht vergessen
worden die Studierenden die Renten
erstmal wollte ganz bewusst diese
Gruppen rausnehmen aus der Energiepreis
pauschale und das war gürtellos und das
muss man diesen Morgen auch nochmals
deutlich zum Ausdruck bringen
wir teilen trotz alledem die Auffassung
dass schlechtes regieren nicht noch mals
oder noch weiterhin von den Bürgern und
Bürger ausgebaut werden muss deshalb
werden wir bei den Energiegesetzen
zustimmen dass die Tagesordnung ergänzt
wird wo wir andere Auffassungen sind da
teilen wir die Auffassung der cdu/csu
was die Fernstraßen mautgesetz angeht
wobei Herr Freiheit muss ihn schon sagen
das ist wirklich so wer davon schlechter
Gesetzgebung redet das mag ja stimmen
aber wer sich an an die scheuer und Maut
erinnert der muss sagen schlechter ging
es nie also insoweit sind sie da als
cdu/csu wirklich ein bisschen
zurückhaltender zeigen mit der Kritik an
schlechter gesetzt geben
[Applaus]
der aufsetzungsauftrag der AFD ich
glaube man hat schon gesehen an dem Wort
bald davon Herr Baumann warum es
sinnvoll ist nicht über den Haushalt des
Bundestags zu diskutieren oder denn das
ist schon ein Begründung an sich und sag
mal dass sie jetzt das Deutsche Institut
für Menschenrechte ins Visier genommen
haben nur weil die festgestellt haben
dass sie dass sie rassistisch und eine
rechtsextreme Partei sind also wenn man
ihren Rednern hier im Bundestag zuhört
tauscht man das Institut eigentlich gar
nicht dafür dass die resso rassistischen
rechtsextrem sind merkt doch jeder wenn
man sich diese Bundestagsdebatten anhört
also insoweit kann ich unsere Hände weg
von diesem Institut hände weg von der
Arbeit die machen das
überparteiisch auch wenn es manche
Parteien manchmal nicht gefällt was
dabei herauskommt aber die Arbeit die
dort gemacht wird ist eine gute Arbeit
und jeder Euro und der hat eingesetzt
wird ist ein gut eingesetzter Euro
deshalb hände weg von diesem Institut
und hände weg von Debatten über
Verfassungsorgane
deshalb kommen wir zum Schluss auch
zwischen Ergebnis alles was mit Energie
zu tun hat dieser Ergänzung stimmt wer
zu Maut werden wir ablehnen und
afd-antrag sowieso vielen Dank
Alexander Ulrich der Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer der Linksfraktion war
der letzte Redner hier in dieser
Geschäftsordnung Debatte
zur absetzungswünsche der Fraktionen SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP die
Fraktion der cdu/csu hat hier zu Teilung
der Frage beantragt und zwar einerseits
über die aufsetzung der zweiten und
dritten Beratung eines Entwurfs des
energiesicherungsgesetzes sowie der
ersten Beratung eines Entwurfs des
Studierenden Energiepreis pauschalen
gesetztes und andererseits über die
aufsetzung der zweiten und dritten
Beratung eines Entwurfs des Bundes
Fernstraßen mautgesetzes zuerst stimmen
wir über die aufsetzung der zweiten und
dritten Beratung des Entwurfs eines
Gesetzes zu Änderungen des
energiesicherungsgesetzes und anderer
energiewirtschaftlicher Vorschriften auf
Drucksache
4.328 sowie der ersten Beratung eines
Entwurfs des Studierenden
energiepreispauschalen Gesetzes auf
Drucksache
4.536 ab wer stimmt für die aufsetzung
das sind die Fraktionen der Linken SPD
Bündnis 90 Grüne FDP cucsu-fraktion wer
stimmt dagegen das ist die afd-fraktion
Enthaltungen
sehe ich nicht dann ist die aufsetzung
damit so beschlossen wie kommen jetzt
zur Abstimmung über die aufsetzung der
zweiten und dritten Beratung eines
Gesetzentwurfs zur Änderung des
Bundesfernstraßen mautgesetzes der
Fraktion SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP auf Drucksachen 3171 und 4476 wer
stimmt für diese aufsetzung das sind die
Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis 90 grünen FDP
wer stimmt dagegen die Fraktion der
Linken
cdu/csu-fraktion auch die afd-fraktion
gibt es Enthaltungen
das sehe ich nicht so aus diese
aufsetzung ist damit ebenfalls
beschlossen nun stimmen wir über den
Antrag der Fraktion der AFD ab eine
Debatte zum Einzelplan 02 deutscher
Bundestag durchzuführen wer stimmt für
diesen Antrag das ist die afd-fraktion
Gegenstimmen
gegen die Stimmen der übrigen Fraktionen
im Hause Enthaltungen sehe ich nicht
dann ist der Antrag der Fraktion der AFD
damit abgelehnt damit kommen wir zur
Feststellung der Tagesordnung der
heutigen 68 der 69 sowie der 70 und 71
Sitzungen mit den genannten Ergänzungen
wer stimmt für diese Tagesordnung
das sind die Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis
90 die Grünen und der FDP wer stimmt
dagegen
und genau um diese Tagesordnung ist es
gegangen zwischen den sechs Fraktionen
man konnte sich vorher nicht einigen
fängt ja schon gut an die haushaltswoche
letztlich bleibt aber alles so wie die
Ampel das wollte nämlich die drei
Gesetze werden in diese Woche noch
reingepackt und das was die AFD wollte
nämlich über den Etat des Bundestages
1,14 Milliarden wegen des Instituts für
Menschenrechte des gesonder zu beraten
das hat der Bundestag hier abgelehnt das
ist auch bislang nicht üblich denn das
Bundespräsident der Bundestag und der
Bundesrat werden so ohne Diskussion
komplett durchgewinkt
25 bis 2026 willkommen zur Beratung der
Einzelpläne und zwar zunächst der drei
Einzelpläne zu denen keine Aussprache
stattfindet ich rufe auf den Einzelplan
01 Bundespräsident und
Bundespräsidialamt mit den
Beschlussempfehlungen des
Haushaltsausschusses ja der
Bundespräsident hat 45 Millionen Euro
zur Verfügung laut Plan ähnlich wie
schon im laufenden Jahr und davon ist
über die Hälfte etwas über 25 Millionen
für Personal vorgesehen eines der
Probleme vielleicht auch der Ampel bei
einem Regierungswechsel gibt es immer
viel neues Personal die Ampel hat aber
jetzt 5000 neue Stellen eingeplant das
ist schon ganz schön heftig natürlich
nicht alle im Bundespräsident hat
Gegenstimmen sehe ich nicht Enthaltungen
sehe ich auch nicht dann ist der
Einzelplan 01 so angenommen ich rufe auf
den Einzelplan nur zwei deutscher
Bundestag mit dem Beschluss im ja und um
diesen Etat ging es ja eben der AFD sie
wollte einzeln darüber diskutieren der
Bundestag bekommt 1,14 Milliarden etwas
mehr als im laufenden Jahr da waren es
1,11 Milliarden davon sind knapp 747
Millionen Euro Personalausgaben
AFD auf Drucksache 4537 vor über den ich
zuerst abstimmen werde wer stimmt für
diesen Änderungsantrag das ist die
afd-fraktion gegen Ausgaben für
parlamentarische Gremien bürgerräte von
4,488 Millionen Euro um 3 Millionen Euro
auf 1,488 Millionen Euro zu kürzen
Abstimmung über den ein oder abgelehnt
in der ausschussfassung wer stimmt für
den Einzelplan 02
das sind die Fraktionen linke SPD
Bündnis 90 grünen FDP cdu/csu-fraktion
Gegenstimmen
Enthaltung
bei Enthaltung der afd-fraktion damit
ist der Einzelplan 02 angenommen ich
rufe auf den Einzelplan 03 Bundesrat mit
der Bundesrat soll
39,68 Millionen Euro bekommen 2022 waren
es
35,29 Millionen Euro ein Großteil der
etat-steigerung enthält auf
Investitionen für Baumaßnahmen der
größte Posten bei den Ausgaben sind mit
20,7 Millionen Euro die Personalkosten
die unter anderem auch diese neuen
Baumaßnahmen
notwendig machen denn auch dort gibt es
immer mehr Angestellte des Bundes
so angenommen ich rufe jetzt auf die
Einzelpläne 08 und 20 Bundesministerium
der Finanzen mit der Beschlussempfehlung
des Haushaltsausschusses auf den
Drucksachen 3.500 08
3526 bricht Erstattung haben die
Abgeordneten Dr Thorsten Rudolf dr Inge
einzelne Sven Christian Kindler
Christoph Meyer Wolfgang Wiehle und dr
Gesine Lötzsch
und für den Bundesrechnungshof dass der
Einzelplan 20 mit der
Beschlussempfehlung des
Haushaltsausschusses auf den Drucksachen
3.526 und 3.527 die Berichterstattung
haben die Abgeordneten Dr Inge gresle dr
Thorsten Rudolph Felix banatschak Frank
Scheffler Ulrike Schielke Ziesing und dr
Gesine Lötzsch
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
90 Minuten beschlossen ich eröffne nun
die Aussprache und das Wort hat zuerst
für die cdu/csu-fraktion DR Matthias
Mittelberg
ja meine Damen und Herren und der
Einzelplan 08 Finanzen und der erzmann
20 Bundesrechnungshof das sind Debatten
da geht es quasi um den Gesamthaushalt
auch der Finanzminister kriegt mehr Geld
das nur bei Plus 843 Millionen aber
jetzt der Material
in der Fraktionsvorsitzender für den
Bereich verdient leider möchte man sagen
deutliche Kritik vor allem deshalb weil
er nicht ehrlich ist sie geben vor dass
sie im kommenden Jahr 2023 die
Schuldenbremse des Grundgesetzes
einhalten tatsächlich haben Sie Herr
Minister Lindner seit Amtsantritt
eigentlich alle denkbaren Methoden
ausgeschöpft um diese Schuldenbremse des
Grundgesetzes zu umgehen
die Einhaltung
die Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse 2023
betonen beschwören sie fast immer wieder
genauso wie die Aussage keine Steuern
erhöhen das ist das Credo der FDP in
dieser Ampel tatsächlich machen sie das
Gegenteil sie machen Schulden wie kein
Finanzminister vor ihnen und die Aussage
kann man ihn nicht ersparen sie sind
Rekord Schulden Macher präziser müsste
man sagen sie sind Rekord Schulden
bevorrater der Haushalt im nächsten Jahr
2023 wird zwar formal ausgeglichen sein
aber nur deshalb weil Sie sich aus dem
Jahr 2021 und in diesem Jahr 2022 so
viel an Schulden auf Vorrat zusammen
gesammelt haben dass sie dann hoffen
können dass sie in die nächsten beiden
Jahren damit unter Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse durchkommen sie haben 60
Milliarden Kredit Ermächtigung per
Nachtrag aus 20 21 gebunkert 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen und 200
Milliarden für ihren doppelwumms sie
nennen das jetzt Abwehrschirm
140 Milliarden machen sie an neuen
Schulden allein im laufenden Jahr das
sind zusammen 500 Milliarden insgesamt
in einem Jahr das ist die höchste
Neuverschuldung die es in dieser
Republik je gab
[Applaus]
betrug die Gesamtverschuldung des Bundes
am Ende des vergangenen Jahres sie
steigern das jetzt um ein volles Drittel
um 500 Milliarden auf 2000 Milliarden
das ist wirklich Rekord dramatisch und
das möchte ich besonders hervorheben ist
dieser Operation mit dem doppelwurms die
200 Milliarden für den Wirtschaft
stabilisierungsform sie buchen dieses
ganze Geld auf dieses Jahr 2022 ausgeben
wollen sie die Gelder und das sagen sie
auch ausdrücklich aber erst in den
Jahren 2023 2024 für gaspreisbremse und
anderes
jeder der irgendwie klar denken kann
fragt sich wenn die das Geld erst im
nächsten und im übernächsten Jahr
brauchen warum nehmen Sie die Kredite
dann nicht erst im nächsten und im
übernächsten Jahr auf jeder ja über ihre
Feinmechanik können wir dann nachher
noch mal reden Herr Volker buchen nein
sie haben die buchungsmechanik geändert
im Haushaltsrecht und genau das führt
dazu dass sie die Schuldenbremse umgehen
können genau diesen Mechanismus haben
sie geschaffen sie buchen alle diese
Gelder auf das Jahr 2022 und kein
vernünftiger Mensch würde das so tun
jeder nimmt die Kredite dann auf wenn er
sie braucht und bringt sie dann hier
durch den Bundestag so dass wir die
Milliarden im Einzelnen überprüfen
können so sie machen diese ganze
Operation nur um pseudomäßig sagen zu
können dass sie im nächsten Jahr die
Schuldenbremse einhalten und der
Bundesrechnungshof hat das sehr klar und
deutlich benannt er sagt diese Kredit
Ermächtigung für den stabilisierungsform
kollidiert mit dem Verfassungsgrundsatz
der Jährlichkeit eine Schulden
regelkonforme Kreditaufnahme dürfen nur
jahresbezogen erfolgen Sondervermögen
mit eigenen Kreditermächtigungen Bergen
sonst die Gefahr des Missbrauchs in sich
eine nicht verfassungskonforme
Kreditaufnahme Morgen und genau darum
geht es hier könnte so durch eine
bereits auf Vorrat erfolgte
Schuldenaufnahme heute umgangen werden
genau das sagt der Bundesrechnungshof
soll mit der Kreditaufnahme auf Vorrat
durch den Stabilisierungsfonds Geschehen
präziser und klarer kann man es nicht
erläutern wie sie die Verfassung hier
umgehen
ihr grüner Amtskollege in
Baden-Württemberg ja bei Jass hat es
sogar noch ganz einfach auf die Formel
gebracht der Bundesfinanzminister will
die Schuldenbremse auf dem Papier
einhalten und hat dafür einen Sondertopf
angefüllt diesen Trick können die Länder
leider nicht anwenden das kann man auch
nicht klarer und deutlicher sagen Herr
Lindner die Aussage kann ich Ihnen auch
nicht ersparen sie sind der
Schuldenbremsen umgehungsminister und
der ich wiederhole es noch mal Rekord
Schulden bevorrater ihr Haushalt
2023 verdient aber auch deshalb Kritik
weil sie keine Vorsorge für die Zukunft
treffen sie reagieren gar nicht auf die
zeitenwände in ihrem eigenen
eigentlichen Haushalt sondern alles was
irgendwie mit Zeitenwende zu tun hat
wird in sondertöpfe in Sondervermögen
und sonst wie geparkt ein wirkliches
umstrukturieren eine neue Priorisierung
von Aufgaben findet nicht statt am
verteid der Haushalt kann man das
exemplarisch sehen der laufende
Haushalten müsste eigentlich anwachsen
um das zwei Prozent Ziel zu erreichen
auch um das umzusetzen was wir mit Ihnen
gemeinsam beschlossen haben im
Bundeswehr finanzierungsgesetz dass wir
nämlich auch Vorsorge treffen dafür wenn
das Sondervermögen ausgelaufen ist all
das tun sie nicht sie frieren den
Haushalt perspektivisch bei 50
Milliarden ein und wir werden dann im
Zweifel in einem Riesensprung in
mehreren Jahren den Haushalt wieder
auffüllen müssen um dann das zwei
Prozent Ziel und die
nato-fähigkeitsziele sicherzustellen
Thema Alterssicherung die SPD und
insbesondere der Bundeskanzler hat damit
ja Werbung gemacht im Wahlkampf und zwar
ganz heftig und hat sich plakatiert als
Kanzler für sichere Renten bisher
geleistet haben Sie in diesem Thema
Alterssicherung nichts die FDP kommt
jetzt mit einem eigentlich guten
Vorschlag nämlich dem Punkt aktienrente
wenn man sich aber ansieht was davon
jetzt übrig geblieben ist von diesem
Ansatz dann wird einem ganz traurig um
die Nase der Kapitalstock soll nicht den
Versicherten sondern der
Rentenversicherung zur Verfügung stehen
die 10 Milliarden sind ein marginaler
Betrag und sie werden jetzt auch nicht
aus Kapital dargestellt sondern auch
Schulden das heißt die Zinsen dafür
werden die Rendite weitgehend auffressen
Bürokratieabbau haben sie uns
versprochen und betonen sie auch immer
wieder als fortschrittskoalition sie
haben sogar eine stelleneinsparung eine
pauschale im Haushalt beschlossen die
erweckt allerdings nur den Eindruck von
Einsparung betont auch hier der
Rechnungshof zurecht denn sie streichen
nur stellen die ohnehin gar nicht
besetzt sind
in Wirklichkeit satteln sie beim
Personal reichlich drauf das können sie
auf ihrer Regierungsbank hier
besichtigen Sie haben die Rekordzahl an
parlamentarischen Staatssekretären mit
37 sie haben 42
regierungsbeauftragte wir müssen ja
eigentlich demnächst anbauen damit ihre
Regierung überhaupt noch Platz findet
und sie haben eine Rekordzahl an
Spitzenbeamten eingestellt das hat mit
Verantwortlichkeit und auch mit
Bürokratieabbau gar nichts zu tun
sie beschreiben sich immer wieder
als
fortschrittskoalition die nachhaltig
agieren würde
tatsächlich und das kann man leider an
diesem Haushalt
besichtigen belasten sie die jüngere
Generation mit immer mehr Schulden und
damit auch mit immer mehr Zinsen das
wird die Handlungsspielräume gerade der
jüngeren in Zukunft dramatisch
eingrenzen auch für ein wichtiges Thema
wie etwa Klimapolitik ihr Haushalt ist
deshalb eines ganz sicher nicht er ist
nicht ehrlich und er ist auch nicht
nachhaltig herzlichen Dank
Matthias Mittelberg der
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzende
der cdu/csu ist hier mit dem Haushalt
scharf ins Gericht gegangen vor allen
Dingen den Bundesfinanzminister hat er
an massiv angegriffen Christoph Meyer
jetzt der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende für diesen Bereich
der FDP moderne wir beschließen den
Haushalt 2023 heute vor einer
schwierigen Gesamtlage aber wir schlagen
mit diesem Haushalt den Weg zurück zu
einer stabilitätsorientierten
Haushaltspolitik ein die Wirtschaftslage
ist fragil die Energiekrise ist nicht
gelöst und wir werden eine Rezession
rutschen und auf diese Herausforderungen
reagieren wir angemessen Bundeshaushalt
203 20 und der wirtschaftliche
Abwehrschirm wirken in Kombination für
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger und die
Unternehmen in unserem Land
blicken wir auf die Zahlen
wir mussten die Ausgaben noch einmal
deutlich erhöhen auch 476 Milliarden
Euro
trotz vielfältiger Belastung bleiben wir
aber mit 20 Milliarden Euro unter den
Ansätzen 2022 und das gelingt die
Investition noch einmal um 20 Milliarden
auf jetzt 71 Milliarden Euro zu steigern
wir holen die Versäumnisse der
Vorgängerregierung Stück für Stück auf
das dauert eine Weile aber wir haben uns
auf den Weg gemacht meine Damen und
Herren
und dann behalten wir Wort
wir entlasten indem wir den
vollständigen Ausgleich der kalten
Progression und die größte
Kindergelderhöhung in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland auf den Weg
bringen
insgesamt haben wir im Haushalt 2023
eine Entlastungsvolumen von fast 50
Milliarden Euro
und uns gelingt es den Einstieg in die
aktienrente zu ermöglichen um unser
Rentensystem abzusichern und dies alles
warten Sie es ab und dies alles tun wir
unter Einhaltung der Schulden bringen
Bremse ermittelt werden das war hart
umstritten in der Koalition aber diese
Koalition bekennt sich mit der
Einhaltung zu soliden Finanzpolitik und
das als solches ist schon ein Erfolg für
sich wir zeigen dass die Schuldenbremse
auch in schwierigen Zeiten funktioniert
das genug Spielraum vorhanden ist
die Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse bleibt
dann mit zentraler Bestandteil für ein
handlungsfähigen Staat und Herr
Mittelberg ich muss mich ehrlich über
ihre Reden wundern Sie persönlich
haben bei der Errichtung von allen
Sondervermögen seitdem sie im Parlament
sind zugestimmt wie biegsam muss man
eigentlich sein dass man das
anschließend kritisiert das zeigt welche
Oppositionspolitik sie ja wirklich
betreiben
und die Union hat im Nachtragshaushalt
2022 das Kunststück fertig gebracht
beides zu tun die Schuldenbremse nicht
einzuhalten 60 Milliarden Euro aus dem
kernetat herauszunehmen und auf der
anderen Seite 600 Milliarden Euro über
ein Sondervermögen in Schaufenster zu
stellen sie sind nicht nur kein Deutsch
besser wenn Sie das hier kritisieren
sondern sie haben schlimmer gemacht wir
ordnen die Finanzen das was sie in den
letzten Jahren nicht auf den Weg
gebracht haben und Sie haben die Stellen
angesprochen
auch daher Mittelberg die groko hat
22.000 Stellen in der letzten Legislatur
aufwachsen lassen 22.000 stellen sie
hatten nicht die Kraft einen
minderungsfaktor einzubauen wie die
Ampel jetzt 3.100 Stellen bauen wir im
nächsten Jahr ab und wir werden
sicherlich in den nächsten Jahren diesen
abbaufahrt so weiter fortsetzen
und wenn sie
hier über die Gas- und Strompreis
Bremsen würden abwehrstürmen reden Herr
Mittelberg sie haben den abgelehnt sie
haben aber in Haushaltsberatung keinen
anderen Finanzierungsvorschlag gemacht
um den Menschen um den Unternehmen zu
helfen das wissen Sie vielleicht nicht
das liegt vielleicht auch daran dass sie
als zuständiger Stellvertreter kein
einziges Mal bei den Haushaltsberatung
im Haushaltsausschuss des Deutschen
Bundestages anwesend war
zur Wahrheit gehört aber auch dazu
dass wir die Zinskosten in den Etat
nochmal um 10 Milliarden Euro anpassen
mussten wir werden jetzt mit einem
Betrag von 40 Milliarden Euro im Jahr
2023 planen 36 Milliarden Euro mehr als
vor zwei Jahren zum Vergleich das sind
die etas für Bildung und Forschung und
Familie und Jugend zusammen diese Summe
steht nicht mehr für zukunftsausgaben
zur Verfügung und an den Zinsumfeld wird
sich absehbar nichts ändern deswegen
müssen wir deutlich sagen die Spielräume
für weitere Ausgabenprogramme sind in
diesem Haushalt sind auf der Bundesebene
nicht mehr gegeben und auch dann müssen
wir sagen dass der Haushalt 2023 in der
Art wie wir Krisenbekämpfung und
Vorsorge betreiben natürlich noch sehr
expansiv ist
wir haben den Pfad des undisziplinierten
mehr ausgebens wie zu Zeiten der großen
Koalition wo immer noch einer
draufgelegt wurde verlassen diesen Weg
müssen wir aber in den nächsten Jahren
konsequent weitergehen denn
nach dem Haushalt ist vor dem Haushalt
das Aufstellungsverfahren für den
Haushalt 2024 beginnt im Frühjahr wir
wollen Wachstumsimpulse setzen um den
Wohlstand in unserer Gesellschaft zu
sichern und gleichzeitig werden wir die
Staatsausgaben konsolidieren diese
beiden Prioritäten müssen in den
nächsten Jahren zusammen gehen
meine Damen und Herren
ich möchte Ihnen allen für die nicht
immer einfachen aber doch sehr
konstruktiven Beratung in den letzten
Monaten danken
[Musik]
ich glaube wir waren alle mit dem Ziel
unterwegs dass wir die Ausgaben kritisch
prüfen und zu einem guten Ergebnis
kommen dieses gute Ergebnis liegt Ihnen
jetzt vor und ich freue mich auf die
Beratung in der laufenden Woche ich
danke Ihnen
Christoph Meyer für die FDP und die
Ampel hat er hier noch einmal den
Haushaltsentwurf verteidigt auf die
Entlastung von 50 Milliarden Euro hin
und die schwierige Situation der
Rezession in die die deutsche Wirtschaft
Stolper Peter Böhringer jetzt äh der
haushaltspolitische Sprache des
Bundeswehr haben es gehört liegt 2023
bei fast 100 90 Milliarden Euro das ist
ein Vielfaches der offiziell von der
Regierung behaupteten Zahl von 45
Milliarden die in den sogenannten
Sondervermögen aufgenommen Schulden
werden formell einfach nicht mitgezählt
ein Trick übrigens Herr Mittelberg ja
den sie mit der Union mit der groko 2021
eingeführt haben das ist die Wahrheit
fast 150 Milliarden Euro Neuverschuldung
werden so 2023 verschleiert die
jahresgenau einzuhaltende Schuldenregel
des Grundgesetzes wird umgangen wir
fordern das Haus auf hier gegen noch im
kontrollklage einzureichen unser Antrag
dazu liegt vor
[Applaus]
Tisch faktisch agiert der Finanzminister
im Haushalt tierischen Notstand
zurückzuführen vor allem auf die dümmste
Energiepolitik der Welt
Energie ist das Lebensblut jeder
modernen Wirtschaft Ideologen und
ignoranten alle Regierungsparteien ist
es in Jahrzehnten fehlgeleiteter
Energiepolitik gelungen Deutschland an
den Rand der d-industrialisierung zu
führen und das sage ich nicht so
leichtfertig das wird den Wohlstand
breiter Bevölkerungsgruppen drastisch
reduzieren die volkswirtschaftlichen
Kosten dieser ideologischen
Energiepolitik sind einfach zu groß man
kann sie nicht aus Steuermitteln
kompensieren trotzdem wird genau das mit
den energiepreisdeckeln nun versucht die
rot gelb grün schwarzen
Realitätsverweigerer versuchen Krisen
symptomatisch statt ursächlich zu lösen
[Applaus]
wir alle bekommen hier jeden Tag
hilferufende Briefe von existenziell
bedrohten Menschen von Unternehmen und
Verbänden alle brauchen mehr Energie
Strom und Gas sonst droht der
massenhafte Abzug von
Produktionskapazitäten und
Arbeitsplätzen doch die amperegierung
beschließt noch nicht einmal die
Verlängerung der Kernkraftnutzung und
was macht die FDP dabei offiziell war
sie monatelang für die Verlängerung der
Kernkraft doch statt wenigstens diese
Minimalforderung irgendwie durchzusetzen
macht der Finanzminister lupenreine
basta Politik gegen die offiziellen
fdp-versprechungen gegen niedrigere
Strompreise gegen die Menschen man
erklärt zur Verlängerung der Laufzeiten
über lächerliche 100 Tage hinaus
schlicht jetzt ist Ende all das zeigt
wieder einmal deutlich auf ein fdp-wort
ist einfach kein Verlass
und dann spricht der Finanzminister auch
noch diesen absurden Satz aus ich
übernehme die Verantwortung für jeden
Euro Schulden ja toll davon kann sich
Deutschland etwas kaufen zumal die
Schäden ihrer Politiker Lindner noch
nachwirken werden wenn sie schon lange
nicht mehr im Amt sind
zur aktienrente wir haben sie eben ganz
stolz gehört von der FDP ein weiteres
neues fdp-projekt man muss es so klar
sagen eine tolle Idee wäre das gewesen
vor 40 Jahren aber selbst dann nicht bei
der gesetzlichen Rentenversicherung denn
diese hat einfach keinen Kapitalstock
den er irgendwie in Aktien investieren
könnte also nimmt die Regierung nun
einfach mal 10 Milliarden Schulden auf
um sie dann irgendwie in den Aktienmarkt
zu stecken und man führt eine riskante
Wette auf aus auf Renditen über die
Kredit Zinsen hinaus die aktienrente
deckt sogar unter der Annahme guter
Aktien und Börsenentwicklung noch nicht
einmal ein zweitausendstel der
rentenzahlungsverpflichtung der nächsten
Jahre bei der GHV das ganze ist ein
schlechter Witz reines Symbolpolitik
[Applaus]
zu den Zinskosten eben schon gehört es
sind 42 Milliarden Euro und auch hier
gilt viele alte Fehlentscheidungen vor
denen die AFD seit Jahren warnt wirken
nun fatale im Haushalt jahrelang hatten
wir einen 0 und negativzinsniveau
jahrelang haben wir als AFD dem
Finanzminister Scholz immer wieder
vorgebetet nutzen Sie dieses niedrige
historische Niveau aus seit 2017 hätte
man nullzinsen teilweise sogar
Negativzinsen für deutsche neue Schulden
auf 30 Jahre fest schreiben können getan
hat es der heutige Kanzler nie der
angerichtete Schaden nur durch dieses
riesige Versäumnis beträgt künftig
mindestens 10 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr
das ist etwa einmal der deutsche
cum-ex-schaden für die nächsten 30 Jahre
jedes Jahr falls es für eine Scholz
geführte Regierung dann leichter
einzuordnen ist
[Applaus]
Realität werden soll 2023 auch ein
hochgefährliches und
gesellschaftsveränderndes Projekt ein
sogenanntes Bürgergeld das dank der
Großzügigkeit der Ampel bedingungslos an
die Bedürftigen aus aller Welt gezahlt
wird
2023 werden dafür viele Milliarden Euro
in den Haushalt eingestellt mal sehen ob
es reichen wird hinzu kommt noch
Kindergeld für nicht EU-Ausländer man
führt hier unglaublich starke
pulfaktoren für noch mehr Zuwanderung
ins deutsche Sozialsystem ein und schon
heute ist klar dass mehr als 40 Prozent
dieser bürgergeldempfänger Ausländer
sein werden Tendenz sehr schnell
steigend
für alle nicht nur für Ausländer nimmt
man zugleich auch noch allen Menschen in
niedrigen Lohngruppen den Anreiz
überhaupt zu arbeiten bei einem nur noch
geringen nettolohnabstand zwischen zum
Beispiel 2000 Euro verdienen und den
neuern bürgergeld-empfängern werden sich
immer mehr Menschen gegen jede Arbeit
entscheiden was ja übrigens heute schon
ein Grund für den Arbeitskräftemangel in
ganz vielen anstrengenden Berufen ist
und da den neuen bürgergeldempfängern ja
auch noch das Wohngeld und auch die
Heizkosten bedingungs- und grenzenlos
gezahlt werden dann könnte der Status
als bürgergeldner demnächst hoch
attraktiv werden und es wird sich in
alle Welt herumsprechen das seine
horende Heizung selbst zahlen der noch
arbeitende Volk wird dagegen in der
Wohnung frieren dürfen
der Regierung ist jedes verantwortungs-
und Gerechtigkeitsgefühl für
leistungsbereite Menschen
abhandengekommen diese Zahlen nämlich
wie immer für solche sozialistische
Ideologie herzlichen
[Applaus]
Redner für die SPD-Fraktion Achim post
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich weiß
das nicht ganz genau
über welchen Bundeshaushalt welchen
Landes mein Vorredner gerade geredet hat
ich rede über den Bundeshaushalt der
stärksten Volkswirtschaft in Europa über
den Bundeshaushalt einer lebendigen
weltoffenen und toleranten Demokratie
und ich rede über den Bundeshaushalt
eines stabilen Landes in der Mitte
Europas mit einer stabilen
handlungsfähigen Regierungen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und
Mittelberg ich darf Sie daran erinnern
dass 81 Tage nach Amtsantritt dieser
Bundesregierung Putin ein aggressiven
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine vom Zaum
gebrochen hat ich darf Sie daran
erinnern dass wir nicht nur akute Krisen
bekämpfen müssen sondern auch
langfristige strukturelle wie eine sich
immer weiter zuspitzende Klimakrise wir
haben vor uns die Transformation unserer
Volkswirtschaft die industrielle
Transformation unserer Volkswirtschaft
zusammengenommen wir leben in einer
wirklich schwierigen
sicherheitspolitischen
Bedrohungslage die selten zuvor seit
1949 und deshalb ist es angemessen
deshalb ist es angemessen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mal darüber zu
reden worum geht es eigentlich in diesem
Bundeshaushalt was ist das Wichtigste
was sind die drei wichtigsten Punkte ich
sag mal ein paar das wichtigste ist die
Handlungsfähigkeit des Staates in diesen
Krisen und Kriegszeiten zu zeigen und
diese Bundesregierung und dieses
Parlament zeigt diese Handlungsfähigkeit
diese staatliche Handlungsfähigkeit
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und guten marktmann manches zu klein zu
spät
[Musik]
erachten finden wenn ich in Brüssel in
anderen europäischen Hauptstadt
unterwegs bin dann höre ich ganz andere
Töne dann ist das vielen unserer Länder
zu früh zu groß zu mächtig und zu
wuchtig vielleicht liegt die Wahrheit
woanders aus meiner Sicht zeigt diese
Bundesregierung und zeigen diese
Koalitionsfraktionen mit den 200
Milliarden für die gaspreisbremse und
die strompreisbremse die beide kommen
und die zeitig kommen werden die
Handlungsfähigkeit diese Staates und
dieser Bundesregierung liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
wir drei entlastungspakete die drei
entlastungspakete über 95 Milliarden
Euro sind alle ausfinanziert ist alles
in diesem Bundeshaushalt das heißt es
wurde viel geredet wir haben gehandelt
und wir werden weiter Handeln liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und
über das Sondervermögen Bundeswehr jetzt
noch mal zu reden das kann man alles
machen ich wir die Mehrheit dieses
Hauses war und ist der Ansicht dass
dieses Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr
notwendig ist um die Bundeswehr zu
ertüchtigen weiter zur tüchtigen und
genau das ist die richtige Politik liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zweiter Punkt zweiter Punkt dieser
Bundeshaushalt zeigt worauf es auch
ankommt auf Zusammenhalt in der
Zeitenwende also wenn ich ein bisschen
mal nach links gucke der größte
einzeletat ist a und S ist Arbeit und
Soziales ungefähr ein Drittel des
gesamten Bundeshaushaltes das heißt
diese Bundesregierung setzt fort und
verstärkt eine soziale Politik für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in diesem Lande
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wenn ich mal ein Beispiel nehmen
kann
ein Kindergeld ab dem ersten Kind ab dem
ersten 23 von 250 Euro das ist kein
Pappenstiel das ist die größte
Kindergelderhöhung in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und worum es auch geht dass der dritte
Punkt es geht um Verantwortung für die
Zukunft die anderen Krisen sind doch
nicht weg weil die Russen und bei
Russland und Putin in der Ukraine
eingefallen ist die Klimakrise spitzt
sich immer weiter zu und deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir rekordinvestitionen der
Kollege Meyer hat darauf hingewiesen in
diesem Bundeshaushalt gegen den
Klimawandel für soziale für die soziale
Zukunft unseres Landes und für die
Transformation unserer Industrie
organisieren und das macht nur diese
Bundesregierung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und eins möchte ich sagen und ganz
wichtiger Punkt das der Kollege Mayer
hat es angesprochen was die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter im
Finanzministerium im Haushaltsausschuss
in den Fraktionen in den letzten Tagen
und Wochen geleistet hat das ist
allergeneur ich ziehe meinen Mut dafür
wenn ich einen hätte
und namentlich
namentlich möchte ich erwähnen Sven
Christian Kindler otro Fricke und Dennis
Rohde der lag an corode erkrankt ist
heute nicht teilnehmen kann schöne Grüße
nach Oldenburg nächstes mal bist du
wieder dabei Dennis
und eins gerade wurde die
Bereinigungssitzung angesprochen die
Bereinigungssitzung wurde
souverän fair ruhig geleitet von
hellgrauen im Vorsitzenden des
Haushaltsausschusses dafür herzlichen
Dank und meinen Respekt
und wenn wir in die Zukunft gucken und
das was wir vor uns haben in dieser
Haushaltsdebatte in den nächsten Wochen
und Monaten
dann muss ich mal eins sagen ich bin
fest davon überzeugt das ist ein
Haushalt der pragmatischen Vernunft das
ist ein Haus als es ein Haushalt der
Zuversicht und diese Zuversicht die
sollten wir uns bewahren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die haben wir
dringend nötig es ist besser
zuversichtlich und selbstbewusst in die
Zukunft zu gehen als verzagt und
verkümmert und mit runtergezogenen
Schultern deshalb liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mein herzlicher Dank an die
Bundesregierung und ganz besonders an
dem Bundesfinanzminister der einen
klugen einen sehr klugen hauseins
Entwurf vorgelegt hat der wurde noch ein
bisschen verbessert in den Beratung ich
glaube da haben sie nichts gegen von
daher zusammengefasst ein guter
Haushaltsentwurf eine kluge Politik der
Bundesregierung schönen Dank
da lächelt der Bundesfinanzminister mild
ein Lob von Achim Post passiert ja auch
nicht jeden Tag die Ampel vermittelt
hier das Signal wir stehen zusammen
Gesine lötchen jetzt die
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Linksfraktion und
haushaltspolitische Sprecherin
für den Kris
enburg sie müssen diese dreiste
Umverteilung endlich stoppen alles
andere ist ein Skandal meine Damen und
Herren
diese Bundesregierung gab ihnen nicht
Vermögensverwalter der gastspekulanten
Stromhändler Waffenhersteller und
immobilienkonzerne sein doch sie weigern
sich beharrlich die krisengewinne zu
besteuern selbst die mickrige
zufallsgewinnsteuer steht in den Sternen
und die stromlobbyisten sorgen dafür
dass diese Steuer auf ein Minimum
eingedampft wird sie Herr Bundeskanzler
haben gesagt wir müssen uns alle
unterhaken aber sie dürfen nicht nur die
Krisengewinner unterhaken das ist nicht
sozial gerecht meine Damen und Herren
es ist doch nicht so dass das höhere
Wohngeld bei den Mieterinnen und Mietern
bleibt sondern das Geld geht zum großen
Teil an die immobilienkonzerne deshalb
fordern wir endlich einen bundesweiten
mietendeckel und endlich den Bau der
versprochenen 100.000 Sozialwohnungen ja
meine Damen und Herren
und es ist doch nicht so
dass die Gas- und strompreisbremse die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zuverlässig vor
Kälte schützt die Bremse macht auch die
Strom und Gasanbieter noch reicher und
deshalb fordern wir endlich eine
übergewinnsteuer meine Damen und Herren
und es ist doch nicht so dass 50 Euro
Hartz IV armen Menschen einen vollen
Kühlschrank bescheren und gleichzeitig
werden all die und Lidl noch reicher wir
als LINKE fordern einen preisdeckel für
Grundnahrungsmittel und null Prozent
Mehrwertsteuer auf diese Produkte das
wäre der richtige Weg
und meine Damen und Herren es ist doch
nicht so dass die zusätzlichen 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr und das größte Bundeswehr
Budget von aller Zeiten von 64
Milliarden Euro die Bundeswehr sinnvoll
ausstattet und vor allem unser Leben
sich vermacht sondern sie treiben die
Aktienkurse der Rüstungsindustrie in den
Himmel deshalb fordern wir endlich mehr
Sicherheit
durch Diplomatie und Verhandlung statt
durch Aufrüstung das wäre der richtige
Weg meine Damen und Herren und an dieser
Stelle muss ich auch sagen wir alle in
diesem Saal verurteilen den
völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg Russlands
gegen die Ukraine
und der Bundesregierung auch dass sie
deutlich den völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg
Erdogans gegen die Kurden verurteilt und
nicht nur von einer schwierigen
Situation spricht dieser Krieg muss
beendet werden meine Damen und Herren
sie haben einen 10 Milliarden Euro
Aktien rentenpaket aus dem Boden
gestampft aber bei der
Kindergrundsicherung arbeiten sie mit
angezogener Handbremse das ist die
falsche Priorität bis Freitag haben wir
noch die Chance etwas zu ändern
herzlichen Dank
so und jetzt dürfen für die Ampel
Fraktionen auf die haushaltspolitischen
Sprecherin nämlich Sven Christian
Kindler für die Bündnisgrünen wie gesagt
haushaltspolitischer Sprecher seiner
Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
meine Damen und Herren und liegen fast
drei Monate Haushaltsberatungen
Ausschuss und im Plenum hinter uns und
ich möchte mehrere Punkte ansprechen die
mir aufgefallen sind erster Punkt wir
zeigen als koalitionsfraktion mit diesem
Bundeshaus seit 23 werde Haus des
Gesetzgeber ist auch gegenüber der
eigenen Regierung die wir tragen wir
haben aus Koalition ein entscheidenden
Stellen maßgabebeschlüsse verabschiedet
da wo es notwendig war auch sperren
eingeführt und haben mit 526
Änderungsanträgen am Bundeshaushalt 23
diesen Entwurf an entscheidenden Stellen
verbessert und auch korrigiert
und manche in der Opposition oder Medien
deuten das dann falsch aber das ist die
ureigene Rolle des Parlaments gegenüber
der Exekutive in der Gewaltenteilung
unserer Demokratie und dieser Aufgabe
sind wir als koalitionsfraktion
nachgekommen und deswegen trägt dieser
Haushalt auch die klare Handschrift des
Parlaments
zweiter Punkt wir stehen als Koalition
zu unserem Wort wir haben als Koalition
in dieser Krise immer gesagt wir lassen
die Menschen mit ihren Sorgen mit ihren
Ängsten in diesen schweren Krisenzeiten
nicht alleine sondern wir unterstützen
Sie wir unterstützen die vielen
Unternehmen die vielen Vereine wir
unterstützen die Einrichtungen jetzt
angesichtsvollzieherin Energiekrise
angesichts des brutalen angesichts
Putins und wir halten unser Wort und das
jetzt konkret in diesem Haushalt um
hat es angesprochen wir haben drei
entlastungspakete in Höhe von 95
Milliarden Euro die wir umsetzen mit
diesem Bundeshaushalt und ein
wirtschaftstabilisierungsfonds an Höhe
von 200 Milliarden Euro zusammen macht
das 300 Milliarden Euro damit
finanzieren wir die gaspreisbremse damit
finden Sie mir die strompreisbremse den
härtefallfonds das Bürgergeld die
wohngeldreform Hilfen für Renten und
Rentner Studierende Azubis das höhere
Kindergeld das 49 Euro Ticket und vieles
vieles mehr wir lassen die Menschen der
schweren Krise nicht alleine mit so
einem Stabilität und Sicherheit in
diesem Krisenzeiten
und ja ja das ist ein großes
entlassungspaket aber das Paket ist eben
auch so groß weil die Krisen leider auch
so groß ist ich will daran erinnern
welcher schweren Lage wir uns befinden
wir haben ein brutalen angustrie mitten
in Europa wir haben eine fossile schwere
Energiekrise und die Klimakatastrophe
eskaliert immer mehr und der Situation
wäre es natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit
dann angesichts Überforderung im
Stillstand zu verharren oder die
Probleme weg zu ignorieren aber das
haben wir nicht gemacht wir gehen diese
Krisen eben entschlossen an und ich will
daran erinnern wo wir gestartet sind als
diese Regierung angefangen hat waren die
Gasspeicher von Peter Altmaier leer
jetzt sind sie über 100%, eine
gefährliche gastmangelage wird diesen
Winter höchstwahrscheinlich vermieten
werden wir haben das größte
Gesetzespaket für erneuerbaren Energien
vor dem Sommer seit 20 Jahren durch den
Deutschen Bundestag gebracht und die
Wirtschaftsdaten besser an sich jetzt
auch und es gibt wieder mehr Zuversicht
in diesem Land alles das haben wir
gemacht das Koalition das zeigt wir
gehen das entschlossen an diese Krisen
und wir zeigen mit diesem Haushalt auch
dass wir Angesicht des russischen
Imperialismus die Ukraine weiter
unterstützen humanitär wir unterstützen
die diplomatisch wir unterstützen Sie
bei der Aufnahme der geflüchteten in
Deutschland wir unterstützen Sie mit
Wirtschaftshilfen und wir unterstützen
Sie auch militärisch und wir werden das
weiter tun
denn wir gucken anders als manche
Nationalisten hier im Haus eben nicht
nur auf das nationale sondern wir wissen
dass wir als in einer gemeinsamen
vernetzten Welt leben und als große
Industrienationen als reich
Industrienation auch eine globale
Solidarität und Verantwortung haben denn
der Angriff den Putins löst ja nicht nur
unschrecklich fassbares Leid aus in der
Ukraine sondern er verschärft auf
Weltmeister weltweit die massiv die
Krisen und deswegen haben wir noch mal
für 20 22 eine Milliarde Euro für den
Kampf gegen Hunger in der
Bereinigungssitzung freigegeben deswegen
werden wir was Auswärtige Amt und das
Entwicklungsministerium jetzt insgesamt
zwei Milliarden Euro für den Haushalt 23
zur Verfügung stellen für humanitäre
Hilfe für Krisenprävention für das
Menschenrecht auf Nahrung wir sagen das
Parlament sehr klar dass wir ein
Schwerpunkt hier auf internationale
Gerechtigkeit leben
und dritter Punkt normalerweise gelten
die Haushaltsberatung ja auch als Stunde
der Opposition wo man die Regierung mit
konkreten Alternativen vor sich
hertreibt oder aber auch und auch in
Krisenzeiten natürlich auch staatsfragen
Verantwortung übernimmt in der
Gemeinschaft der DemokratInnen und
Demokraten ich hätte mir das bei der
Union diesen Haushaltsverfahren auch
gewünscht ich hoffe dass wir am nächsten
Haus das waren anders läuft denn wir
haben es leider nicht gesehen und wir
meine Kritik konkret machen am 21
Oktober haben wir hier im Deutschen
Bundestag die 200 Milliarden Euro
Finanzierung für den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsform
beschlossen und die Union hat dagegen
gestimmt
Finanzminister
als
und die Union hat damals um 21 Oktober
dagegen gestimmt weil sie gesagt haben
sie wollen keine Finanzierungen über der
Sondervermögen und ich hatte erwartet
dass sie im Haus das Verfahren dann
andere Alternative
Finanzierungsvorschläge vorlegen zum
Beispiel gerechte Steuererhöhungen
Einsparung oder eben auch eine
Finanzierung über die notfallregel der
Schuldenbremse 23 das haben Teil
Mittelberg ja auch eine Debatte am 21
Oktober angedeutet aber es kam nichts es
kam kein Antrag in der
Bereinigungssitzung gar nichts Herr
Mittelberg vielleicht wissen sie es ja
nicht sie waren ja nie im
Haushaltsausschuss im gesamten Verfahren
aber sie haben keine andere
ernährungsverträge vorgelegt für die
Finanzierung
und ich will die Union auch ernst sehen
was Opposition und wenn ich die Union
ernst nehmen will dann muss ich ja
verstehen sie haben die Finanzierung für
die Strom- und gaspreisbremse abgelehnt
sie haben keine Alternative
Finanzierungsvorschläge im
Haushaltsverfahren vorgelegt und ich
kann Ihnen sagen Hausarzt klaren
Haushalts Wahrheit gilt auch für die
Opposition
und wenn sie keine konkrete Finanzierung
vorlegen dann heißt es im Ende auch sie
leben diese Hilfen ab sie wollen keine
energiehilfen für die Menschen und für
Unternehmen sie lassen den Wecker im
Regen stehen sie lassen die Menschen in
der Kälte alleine mit ihren mit ihrer
Politik aber das werden wir konkret
nicht zulassen
ja ich würde sagen wir Treffer hat
gesessen sie haben eben konkret nichts
vorgelegt im Ausschuss was die
Finanzierung gerechtfertigt hätte immer
nur populistisch kritisieren was wir
anders machen sollen das Regierung aber
keine konkreten
Änderungsanträge Vorschlägen das geht so
nicht also Union sie müssen schon mal
sich entscheiden welche Opposition sie
wollen dann konstruktiv staatstragend
und nur populistisch
vierter Punkt wir stabilisieren nicht
nur eine Krisen sondern denken jetzt
auch an das morgen die Klimakatastrophe
eskaliert immer mehr deswegen haben wir
auch noch mal sehr konkret
Energieeffizienz internationalen
nationalen Klimaschutz in dem Haus ist
Entwurf gestärkt wir haben 1,5
Milliarden Euro für die Schiene
zusätzliche bereitgestellt und wir haben
700 Millionen Euro für kommunale
Investition bereitet wir haben
rekordination in diesem Haushalt das
zeigt wir gehen die Krisen entschlossen
an wir bauen jetzt soziale ökologisch
für die Zukunft um deswegen kann ich nur
die empfehlen dem Bundeshaushalt
zuzustimmen danke
Sven Christian Kindler der Haushälter
der Bündnis Grünen hat festgestellt
dieser Etat eine klare Handschrift des
Parlaments anders wird das Christian
Hase sehen der haushaltspolitische
Sprecher der CDU Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zunächst einmal
auch Genesungswünsche in Richtung Dennis
Rode hätte ihn gerne heute hier gehabt
vielleicht schafft das ja bis Donnerstag
mal Corona geht das ja manchmal schnell
ja über 45 Milliarden neue Schulden für
den Bund dass das traurige Ergebnis der
Haushaltsberatung 45 Milliarden die
unsere Kinder irgendwann mit Zins und
Zinsen sind zurückzahlen müssen 45
Milliarden Euro die unsere
Handlungsfähigkeit in der Zukunft
einschränken dabei waren es im
Regierungsentwurf nur 17 Milliarden Euro
die Ampel hält das haben wir ja heute
schon gehört zwar die Schuldenbremse ein
aber sie nutzt den
verschuldungsspielraum der Konjunktur
Komponente vollkommen nutzt die
vollkommen aus aber
sollte man nicht tun müssen wir haben
Krisen seit der Kollege Kindler gerade
noch mal darauf hingewiesen da hätte man
etwas Geld zurückhalten können aber so
etwas kommt in der ampelogik leider
nicht vor da wird keine Vorsorge
behalten zum Beispiel für die
Sozialversicherung da schiebt man jetzt
an die Beitragszahler an also wenn Sie
eine Erhöhung ihrer Beitragszahlung in
der Krankenversicherung bekommen das
hätten wir anders regeln können da hat
die Ampel andere Prioritäten gesetzt
von Interessen da kriegt die Frau Roth
200 Euro Begrüßungsgeld in der
Erwachsenenwelt Herr halbe kommt seinen
Bürgergeld Frau bärwok acht Millionen
Euro für selbst ernannte Seenotretter
Herr Wissing bekommt ein billig Ticket
für die urbanen Räume und unser
Bundesfinanzminister darf weitere
Darlehen aufnehmen diesmal für eine
aktienrente nur eine Dame bekommt leider
nichts das ist Frau Lamprecht das ist
aber Dings dann auch erstmal richtig so
weil sie hat besser nicht gezeigt dass
sie in der Lage ist sie zur Verfügung
gestellten Mittel auch tatsächlich
auszugeben das hätten wir uns anders
gewünscht wir haben gezeigt da hätte man
ordentlich drauflegen müssen denn da
muss endlich Dampf in die Sache rein
die Koalition handelt also ganz nach dem
Motto die neuen Schulden brauchen wir ja
nicht mehr zurückzahlen dann sind wir
schon lange nicht mehr im Amt im
ampelsprecht heißt das dann alle drei
Koalitionspartner finden sich in diesem
Haushalt wieder dabei verkennt die Ampel
an welchen Kipppunkt unsere Wirtschaft
steht welche Investitionen in Sicherheit
erforderlich werden und dass die
Tragfähigkeit der Staatsfinanzen doch in
Gefahr sind dabei müsste sie das doch
eigentlich wissen die
Entschließungsanträge der FDP zum ersten
und zweiten Nachtrag 2020 da kann ich
reingucken da steht komplette Auflösung
der Rücklage da steht wir fordern einen
Tilgungsplan auch für die Schulden im
Rahmen der konjunkturkomponente dabei
sollten Privatisierungserlöse können
über 2 Milliarden erzielt werden da war
die Forderung nach einem
Wirtschaftsförderungsprogramm leider
leider ist davon nichts mehr übrig
deshalb waren wir aufgefordert
Vorschläge zu machen wir haben das
gemacht wir haben einen Einsparungen
19 Milliarden ermittelt durch Abbau von
haushaltsresten Auflösung der Rücklage
Privatisierungserlöse und um
Förderprogrammen leider sind uns die
ampelfraktion da nicht gefolgt dabei
wäre noch ein Impuls einen Neustart
etwas was in Richtung
Wirtschaftsförderung geht in diesem Land
jetzt im Augenblick so wichtig um
bisschen mehr zukunftsgläubigkeit um ein
bisschen mehr Zutrauen in unserem Land
wieder zu erreichen und die
Verunsicherung und detargie in diesem
Land zu nehmen
unsere Schwerpunkte waren Forschung und
Erprobung alternativen
Antriebstechnologien bei ihnen nichts
vorhanden weitere stillgelegte weiter
Nutzung stillgelegter als förderfelder
für Geothermie Unterstützung von
Handwerksbetrieben beim
energieträgerwechsel Aufbau von
rohstoff-offensive fürs antworten die
effizientere Gestaltung unserer Jugend
berufsagenturen Förderung von Mädchen
und Frauen in den Mund Berufsfeldern
Stärkung des girlsdays oder ein
inklusiven digitalpakt für berufliche
Bildung all das konnten sie
offensichtlich nicht mitgehen wir stehen
als CDU und CSU für die stärkeren der
äußeren und inneren Sicherheit wir
müssen den Bundeswehr Etat aufstocken
damit die laufenden Ausgaben nicht
weiter die in Diskussion aus diesem Etat
verdrängt wir wollen die Aufstockung der
Notfallreserve beim Getreide wir
brauchen moderne Geräte und Ausrüstung
für Katastrophenschutz und Bundespolizei
wir wollen das THW stärker stärken wir
brauchen eine verbesserte
Notstromversorgung in unserem Land
genauso wie eine
trinkwassernotversorgung und wir
brauchen ein Investitionsprogramm für
den Starkregen all das haben sie leider
nicht mitgemacht wir waren für die
Anhebung der Pendlerpauschale und zwar
ab dem ersten Kilometer damit endlich
mal wieder Politik für den ländlichen
Raum gemacht wird die ist seit Übernahme
dieser Regierung nicht mehr da meine
Damen und Herren Deutschland kann doch
mehr wir müssen es nur wollen an dieser
Stelle
jetzt will ich auf ein zwei Punkte
eingehen erstmal Kollege Post
1 ist noch nicht richtig verstanden
unsere Hauptkritik ist der normale
Haushalt wird ganz normal weitergeführt
es werden die ampelprojekte durchgeführt
wie sie im Koalitionsvertrag beschrieben
wurden und alles was Krise ist das
bildet sich jetzt alles in
Sondervermögen ab und damit blendet man
Stück halt die Realität und
Wirtschaftlichkeit aus ich kann nicht
einfach sagen da nehme ich Milliarden
Schulden dafür aus ich muss beides
miteinander kombinieren und vernünftig
in die Zukunft zu gehen
der zweite Punkt wir müssen uns das
Thema haushaltsvorzukommen die
Investitionen werden höher dass es
richtig aber die Haushaltsreste steigen
noch viel schneller weil die Ministerien
das Geld nicht ausgeben man sieht doch
die vielen roten Karten die auch von
ihrer Fraktion von den ampelfraktionen
verteilt wurden wo gesagt wir wollen
Berichte wir sperren hier Mittel weil
wir gar nicht wissen wo die Regierung
das Geld für ausgibt und der Kindler das
war der Grund warum wir das beim WSF
nicht mitkommen können wir wissen bis
heute nicht wie die Bremsen gestaltet
sind wir wissen nicht wie die
Gewinnabschöpfung die neue Steuer wie
die ausgestaltet sind wir konnten ihnen
noch keinen Blankoscheck ausstellen
hierzu überhaupt wir werden nicht für
die Hilfen dass es unredlich danke schön
Christian Haase der haushaltspolitische
Sprecher der CDU CSU liegt die hier den
Finger in den Wunde aus Sicht zumindest
der Union und jetzt spricht Christian
Lindner der Bundesfinanzminister
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wir beraten diesen Haushalt in Zeiten
größter wirtschaftlicher Unsicherheit
viele Familien sorgen sich darum wie sie
über die Runden kommen viele
mittelständische Betriebe die seit
vielen Generationen in Familienhand sind
sorgen sich um ihre eigene
wirtschaftliche Existenz und bei diesen
Haushaltsberatungen bei dieser Debatte
bei einzelnen Beiträgen am heutigen
Vormittag habe ich den Eindruck dass die
gesellschaftliche und ökonomische
Realität nicht bei jedem angekommen ist
Kollege Haase
Kollegah Haase die beste Form der
Wirtschaftsförderung und Sie haben ja
von Wirtschaftsförderung gesprochen die
beste Form der Wirtschaftsförderung ist
doch dass ein Betrieb angesichts der
steigenden Gaspreise überhaupt noch
produzieren kann und deshalb ist es
richtig dass die Koalition eine Strom
und eine gaspreisbremse auf den Weg
gebracht hat
hier habe ich im übrigen die habe ich im
übrigen auch keinen Widerspruch der
Opposition gehört von keinem von ihnen
wir stimmen ja auch offensichtlich darin
überein dass wir die Menschen und die
Wirtschaft mit den ruinösen Preisspitzen
nicht alleine lassen dürfen wir müssen
doch unsere wirtschaftliche Stärke
mobilisieren um unsere wirtschaftliche
Stärke auch für die Zukunft zu erhalten
deshalb ist es doch auch notwendig dass
wir in enormer Weise fiskalische Stärke
projizieren um einen Abwehrschirm
aufzustellen das haben sie nicht in
Frage gestellt und das ist auch richtig
dass sie es nicht in Frage stellen denn
wir müssen in diesen Zeiten dafür sorgen
dass das erhalten bleibt was wir uns
über Jahrzehnte erarbeitet haben
offen bleibt nur
offen bleibt nur und umstritten dann
zwischen den Koalitionen Regierung
einerseits und der Opposition
andererseits die Frage der Finanzierung
jetzt könnte man auf die Idee kommen wir
finanzieren das mit Steuererhöhungen der
Kollege Friedrich Merz hatte das ja ins
Gespräch gebracht im Zusammenhang mit
der Ertüchtigung der Bundeswehr ich
erinnere mich an diese Debatte der
Sachverständigenrat hat ist ebenfalls
angesprochen konnte übrigens aber auf
Nachfrage nicht ein Volumen oder ein
Mittel angeben sondern nur abstrakt
wurde das ins Gespräch gebracht ich
halte das für falsch angesichts der
großen Unsicherheit die wir haben
angesichts der privaten
investitionsbedarfe in saubere
Technologie angesichts der infrage
gestellten Wettbewerbsfähigkeit übrigens
auch durch den Inflation Redaktion Act
der Vereinigten Staaten wäre es ein
gefährliches
makroökonomisches Experiment in diesen
Zeiten auch noch die Steuern zu erhöhen
deshalb haben wir uns dagegen
entschieden
dagegen entschieden im Gegenteil die
Koalition hat bereitflächig Entlastungen
beschlossen dabei handelt sich um die
steuerliche Abzugsfähigkeit
beispielsweise der
Rentenversicherungsbeiträge die wir
verbessert haben Verbesserungen beim
häuslichen Arbeitszimmer Verbesserungen
beim Arbeitnehmer Pauschbetrag bereits
zu Beginn diesen Jahres
Sparer-Pauschbetrag ja und auch die
kalte Progression wird vollständig
ausgeglichen allein das sind
Mindereinnahmen von
18,6 Milliarden Euro im nächsten Jahr
wann soll es einen steuerlichen
Inflationsausgleich geben wenn ich in
Zeiten hoher Inflation und das macht die
Koalition und ich füge hinzu
wir werden auch über weitere steuerliche
Maßnahmen sprechen müssen mit Blick auf
den Haushalt
2024 wir müssen ja die Konjunktur
anschieben und da ist auch ein
sichtbarer steuerlicher Impuls notwendig
der Bundeskanzler hat bereits bei seiner
Regierungserklärung gesagt er spreche
sich für eine investitionsprämie bzw
super Abschreibung aus und damit wir aus
dieser Krise uns heraus investieren
können im privaten Bereich ist das eine
Maßnahme die 2024 rechtzeitig sein
könnte
der Haushaltsgesetzgeber wird noch
darüber sprechen der Bundesregierung
wird ihren Haushaltsentwurf 2024 im
nächsten Jahr ja erst vorlegen deshalb
spreche ich hier ja noch im Konjunktiv
Potenzial ist liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Koalition hat einen
Bundeshaushalt aufgestellt der die
Schuldenbremse achtet übrigens ist die
flexibler als manche denken denn sie
erlaubt im Konjunkturverlauf auch höhere
Ausgaben innerhalb des Bundeshaushaltes
verfolgen wir unsere regulären
politischen Vorhaben die krisenbedingten
Mehrausgaben des abwehrschirms wir haben
wir im Wirtschaft und
Stabilisierungsfonds gebunden übrigens
auch deshalb weil wir nicht wissen wie
sie Strom und Gaspreise entwickeln
deshalb brauchen wir jetzt
Handlungsmöglichkeiten und auch
flexibilitäten um in diesen im nächsten
im übernächsten Jahr regieren zu können
die cdu/csu kritisiert dass wir die
regulären Vorhaben der Koalition unter
der Schuldenbremse und die Bewältigung
in der Krisenfolgen dass wir die
voneinander separieren und diese Kritik
diese Kritik der stellen wir uns und
dafür gibt es ja auch Argumente die auf
ihrer Seite sind und dennoch bei der
Abwägung von pros und konz haben wir uns
am Ende für diesen Weg entschieden weil
es der sichtbarste Beleg dafür ist dass
wir zwar die haushaltspolitische
Normalität noch nicht erreicht haben das
ist aber der Anspruch dieser Koalition
ist schnellstmöglich zum Prinzip
zurückzukehren dass nur das verteilt
werden kann was zuvor erwirtschaftet
worden ist
der Bundesfinanzminister hier mit einer
prägnanten Rede Tenor auf jeden Fall ist
dieser Haushalt besser als wenn man die
Steuern erhöht mit ihm nicht Kai
Gottschalk jetzt für die afd-fraktion
ist der finanzpolitische Sprecher der
AFD
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
verehrte Kollegen über Steuerzahler da
draußen muss darauf ein Herr Kollege
Lindner es ist ja wohl das Minimum dass
die Regierung das versucht zu reparieren
was sie durch ihre gescheiterte
Energiepolitik verursacht haben aber sie
lindern es nur man könnte auch sagen sie
Linden an ihr ein bisschen aber sie
heben den Schaden doch nicht auf das ist
die pflichtverdammt noch mal das zu tun
gegenüber den Unternehmern den
Steuerzahlern die Angst vor der nächsten
Stromrechnung haben meine Damen und
Herren
und eine Korrektur Herr Lindner das Jahr
2022 haben sie vergessen sie sagen die
kalte Progression gleichen sie aus nein
wenn nur in Teilen da könnten wir in die
Debatte gehen aber sie fangen es zum
ersten Januar 2023 an meine Damen und
Herren dieses Jahr ist anscheinend
nichts teuer geworden auch das
verschweigen sie es ist eine Expos der
Entlastung meine Damen und Herren
sie Rühen sich also doch damit in diesem
Haushalt dass sie die Schuldenbremse
einhalten das mag nach ihren
juristischen kriegsereien für sie so
funktionieren auch wenn viele Experten
meine Damen und Herren das wirklich
anders sehen aber ich frage mich ehrlich
ob es in Zeiten von galoppierender
Inflation und einer sich anbahnenden
Rezession auch richtig und notwendig ist
diese juristischen Spielräume
auszunutzen meine Damen und Herren ich
würde eher sagen sie tricksen und
balancieren beim Haushalt wie es
Wirecard bei den Bilanzen getan hat und
das Ende bei der Wirecard AG das kennen
wir hier alle meine Damen und Herren im
Parlament
aber vermutlich wollen Sie diese Debatte
auch nicht hören sie haben ja nicht ohne
Grund das Thema der bundesschulden und
der allgemeinen Finanzverwaltung ohne
Debatte für Freitag auf die Tagesordnung
gesetzt ich erinnere Sie daran dass Sie
diese im März noch bei den hier zu
beratenden einzutleben 08 und 20 unter
die Überschrift allgemeiner
finanzdebatte beraten haben vermutlich
eben wollen sie ihm nicht über die
Verdopplung der Kreditaufnahme und die
vom Bundesrechnungshof attestierten
verdeckten Schulden reden meine Damen
und das ist keine Transparenz das ist
schuldenkoalition live und so verbauen
sie die Zukunft der vielen jungen
Menschen die hier sehr auf den Tribünen
die Schulden von heute das in eure
Steuererhöhung und die Renten die
gekürzt werden von morgen meine Damen
und Herren
also ein Schelm wäre auch böses dabei
denkt und Liebe Steuerzahler wenn Sie
nun dachten dass diese Bundesregierung
mit einem von der FDP geführten
Finanzministerium in Zeiten wo eben so
viele Menschen Angst vor den nächsten
Rechnungen haben in der
Bereinigungssitzung des Haushalts als
schones genutzt hätte um den Rotstift
und Sparmaßnahmen durchzudrücken nein
auch da Fehlanzeige dieser
Bundesregierung meine Damen und Herren
betreibt Raubbau an ihrer Zukunft sie
stellt das größte Risiko für die Zukunft
da und nicht der herbei zitierte und
geredete angebliche Klimawandel meine
Damen und Herren
und machen Sie sich selbst ein Bild
schauen Sie in die Einzelpläne ich nehme
hier einfach mal den Einzelplan 08
Ausgaben von 9,7 Milliarden Euro damit
steigt dieser Plan in diesem Jahr
alleine um zehn Prozent meine Damen und
Herren hier geht wohl auch das Motto
Quantität statt Qualität und wenn ich
mir die bildungsabläufe einiger
Abgeordneter dieser schuldenkoalition
ankomme ist das auch kein Wunder ich
zitiere mit Erlaubnis der Präsidentin
deutsche Verwaltung explodiert
ampelregierung stammt 10.000 Stellen aus
dem Boden der Staat insgesamt also wir
beschäftigen 300.000 Personen
kostenpunkt 40 Milliarden Euro meine
Damen und Herren dieser ampelregierung
hält die Bürger in unserem Land zum
Sparen an gleichzeitig vernichtet aber
die Inflation und ihre Ausgaben Politik
die Zukunft dieses Landes sie hätten die
Zeichen der Zeit erkennen müssen Herr
Lindner und die gesamte Regierung der
Kanzler ist nicht da auch das ist wieder
klar und alle ideologische motivierten
und überflüssigen Posten streichen
sollen Personal Neubau Effektivität
Effizienzsteigerung der Ministerien und
Behörden während einer Tagesordnung
gewesen diese Chance haben sie kläglich
verpasst der Steuerzahler der Zukunft
wird es zahlen müssen die Quittung meine
Damen und Herren werden sie hoffentlich
dieser schuldenkoalition schon bald bei
der Wahl hier in Berlin und hoffentlich
auch bei den nächsten Wahlen in den
Landtagen geben wir machen da nicht mit
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion dr
Thorsten Rudolf
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren
Weltmeister wird nur wer neben der
spielerischen Qualität auch über den
nötigen Zusammenhalt verfügt diesen zu
schlagen indem sie verschiedene
gesellschaftliche Gruppen gegeneinander
ausspielen leider sitzen einige davon
auch in diesem Raum dass meine lassen
Sie es mich deshalb ganz klar sagen die
Ampelkoalition spielt dieses Spiel nicht
mit wir setzen auf Zusammenhalt
Zusammenhalt in der Zeitenwende das
heißt erstens wir sind solidarisch mit
denen die es nötig haben wir lassen es
nicht zu dass unser Land das unsere
Gesellschaft gespalten werden deshalb
hat diese Koalition drei
entlastungspakete von insgesamt 95
Milliarden Euro geschnürt deshalb hat
diese Koalition zusätzlich ein
Abwehrschirm von 200 Milliarden Euro
gespannt um mit der Strom- und
gaspreisbremse die Belastungen durch die
hohen Energiekosten ab zum mindern um
Arbeitsplätze zu sichern und um die
Strukturen unserer Wirtschaft zu
erhalten deshalb entlastet diese
Koalition die Breite Mitte der
Einkommensbezieher mit dem
inflationsausgleichsgesetz spürbar und
deshalb unterstützt diese Koalition vor
allem auch mit dem Bürgergeld mit der
Erhöhung des Kindergelds auf 250 Euro
und mit dem neuen wohngeldlos gerade
diejenigen die inmitten einer der
schwersten Krisen seit Bestehen der
Bundesrepublik dringend Hilfe nötig
haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Zusammenhalt in der Zeitenwende das
heißt zweitens wir stehen zu unserer
internationalen Verantwortung und wir
lassen die Menschen nicht im Stich wir
sind solidarisch mit unserer
europäischen und transatlantischen
Partnern und wir sind solidarisch mit
den Ländern des globalen Südens deshalb
haben wir eine Milliarde Euro für den
Kampf gegen den Hunger noch in diesem
Jahr freigegeben deshalb erhöhen wir für
das nächste Jahr die etas von außen und
Entwicklungshilfeministerium zusätzlich
um jeweils eine Milliarde Euro deshalb
stärken wir den weltweiten Kampf gegen
den Hunger deshalb stärken wir die
humanitäre Hilfe deshalb stärken wir die
zivile Krisenprävention aber deshalb
investieren wir auch in unsere
Sicherheit und Freiheit und erfüllen
unsere Bündnis Verpflichtungen deshalb
schließen wir jetzt schnell die
Fähigkeitslücken unserer Bundeswehr mit
der Rekordsumme von erneut über 50
Milliarden Euro im Verteidigungshaushalt
plus zusätzlich erstmals rund 8,4
Milliarden Euro aus dem 100 Milliarden
Euro Sondervermögen
meine Damen und Herren Zusammenhalt in
der Zeitenwende das heißt drittens wir
sind auch solidarisch mit unseren
Kindern und kinderskindern und stellen
die Weichen für eine gute Zukunft
deshalb investieren wir in die
Digitalisierung in Forschung und
Wissenschaft und in die Transformation
unserer Wirtschaft deshalb stellen wir
allein über den
klima-35 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung
im nächsten Jahr deshalb investieren wir
massiv in die Gebäudesanierung in die
dekarbonisierung unserer Wirtschaft in
den Marktdurchbruch der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft in den Ausbau der
Lage Infrastruktur oder auch in die
Digitalisierung der Schiene
und Solidarität mit unseren Kindern
heißt auch das betone ich ausdrücklich
dass diese Ampelkoalition eine durch und
durch seriöse und verantwortungsvolle
Finanzpolitik Macht dazu gehört erstens
dass die krisenbedingten Mittel für die
Bundeswehr und die energiehilfen jeweils
gesondert ausgewiesen werden transparent
und mit klarer Zweckbestimmung und dazu
gehört auch dass diese Ampelkoalition im
Bundeshaushalt 2023 die Schuldenbremse
wieder einhält die Solidität dieser
Koalition beweisen dabei insbesondere
zwei der wichtigsten Kennziffern 1 wird
die Schuldenquote in den nächsten Jahren
trotz aller entlastungspakete und
abwehrschirme leicht sinken sinken meine
Damen und Herren mit anderen Worten
Deutschland und seine öffentlichen
Finanzen werden nach der Krise in etwa
so da stehen wie vor der Krise wir
unterbrechen lediglich die schnelle
Entschuldigung der letzten Jahre
und deswegen ist es auch so
verwunderlich dass sie als Opposition
immer nur auf die absoluten Zahlen
eingehen und damit ökonomisch nicht mal
die halbe Wahrheit erzählen es ist
vielmehr klar Christian Lindner setzt
hier den verantwortungsvollen
finanzpolitischen Kurs von Olaf Scholz
fort und zweitens und sicherlich genauso
bemerkenswert in diesem Zusammenhang der
Bund plant trotz schuldenblemse im
nächsten Jahr mit rekordinvestitionen
von 71 Milliarden Euro 71 Milliarden
Euro das ist eine weltmeisterliche
Investitionsquote meine Damen und Herren
die für 2023 geplante Neuverschuldung
wird gerade nicht verfrühstückt sondern
komplett und vollständig in die Zukunft
unseres Landes investiert damit unsere
Kinder es besser haben liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen kurz und
gut Deutschland spielt im kommenden Jahr
mit einer starken Abwehr gegen die
großen Krisen mit einem mindestens
genauso starken Angriff um die Zukunft
zu gewinnen und um unser Land und die
Welt sicherer gerechter und
klimafreundlicher zu machen und weil wir
dabei auf mannschaftliche
Geschlossenheit setzen und weil wir auf
Zusammenhalt in der zeitenwände sitzen
wird unser Land ganz vorne mitspielen
davon bin ich überzeugt herzlichen Dank
der Bundestag debattiert über Finanzen
und Bundesrechnungshof über den
Gesamthaushalt quasi in der zweiten und
dann dritten Lesung jetzt als nächste
Rednerin Janine Wissler eine die
Fraktionschefin Ballon der Linksfraktion
Dietmar Bartsch ist der andere
Fraktionschef
soziale Spaltung sogar ihr
Sachverständigenrat empfiehlt in dieser
Sinne und Vermögende zu erhöhen und ich
sage ihnen wenn sie schon nicht als auf
uns als Linke gehören ja dann hören Sie
doch wenigstens auf die Sachverständigen
die sie selber benannt haben und erhöhen
Sie in dieser Situation die Steuern für
die Reichen in diesem Land für Menschen
mit kleinem Einkommen die von Armut
betroffen sind tun sie viel zu wenig in
diesem Haushalt die Kinder
Grundsicherung die verschieben die
schieben Sie auf die lange Bank aber bei
der aktienrente da ging es deutlich
schneller und beim Bürgergeld erleben
wir ein unwürdiges Schmierentheater auf
dem Rücken der Beschäftigte der
Betroffenen erst legt die Ampel einen
mehr als dürftigen Gesetzentwurf vor der
mit der Überwindung von Hartz IV
wirklich überhaupt nichts zu tun hat 53
€ mehr hat doch nichts mit Respekt zu
tun die sie den Menschen versprochen
haben meine Damen und Herren und diese
mickrigen Verbesserungen bei
Schonvermögen bei zwangsumzügen und
Sanktionen von denen die Menschen die so
wie schon im Hartz iv-bezug sind sowieso
nichts haben das muss man ja immer
wieder sagen diese mickrigen
Verbesserungen werden aller Voraussicht
nach dem Vermittlungsausschuss nicht mal
überleben dank der Union mit
freundlicher Unterstützung der FDP und
das ist wirklich beschämend was sie dort
getan haben meine Damen und Herren weil
die Union den Menschen nicht mal die
kleinste Verbesserung gönnt und versucht
Niedriglöhner gegen
sozialleistungsbezieher auszuspielen das
ist chemik als ob hart arbeitende
Menschen von denen sie immer reden
irgendeine Verbesserung davon hätten
wenn die alleinerziehende hat vier
BezieherInnen zwar sanktioniert wird
weil sie einen Termin verpasst hat oder
zwangsumziehen muss nein was diese
Menschen brauchen das sind wirksame
tarifreie Gesetze und höhere
Mindestlöhne und da war die EU immer
dagegen er hat immer dagegen gestimmt
also deswegen ist es heuchlerisch dass
sie sich als Anwalt der hart arbeitenden
Menschen darstellen Frau Präsident ich
komme zum Schluss das ist ein Wettbewerb
der Schäbigkeit auf dem Rücken der
Betroffenen den wir euch beteiligen
während wir ihnen wären bei Ihnen die
Superreichen diesem Land da sind ihnen
selbst schon Vermögen in Milliardenhöhe
nicht hoch genug also von daher da
sollte man ansetzen bei den
Schonvermögen der Superreichen aber doch
nicht bei den Altersrücklagen von
Menschen im sozialleistungsbezug vielen
Dank
Janine Wissler ist natürlich die
Parteivorsitzende der Linken panormal
der Damen und Herren dabei ich glaube
ich ein wenig abgelehnt aber die
Kollegen haben es ja richtig
eingeblendet apropos eingeblendet sie
sehen ist schon links im kleinen Bild
wir erwarten hier gleich Stellungnahmen
zunächst der Fraktionen der Ampel zu der
Einigung beim Bürgergeld ist
offensichtlich gegeben hat in den
Vorverhandlungen denn der
Vermittlungsausschuss zwischen Bundestag
und Bundesrat sitzt sehr erst morgen
doch zurück zum Haushalt mit Sebastian
Schäfer und in bündnisgrün unser Land
steckt in der wahrscheinlich
schwierigsten Situation seitdem es als
demokratischer Staaten 1949 begründet
wurde
die Multidimensionalität so meine Damen
und Herren und so schnell geht es
manchmal jetzt meine Damen und Herren so
schnell geht's manchmal jetzt springen
wir zurück auf die Fraktionsebene über
uns dort jetzt also Katja Mast schon zu
sehen Britta Hasselmann und Johannes
Vogel die Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer der ampelentwicklung vor
allem im Energiebereich sind wir in noch
schwereres Fahrwasser gekommen
und diese Krisen sind alles andere als
ausgestanden sie werden auch nicht
schnell vorbei gehen wir müssen uns auf
eine grundlegend veränderte Normalität
einstellen gesellschaftlich wie
politisch ja und das ist live
ich heute konstatieren das ist meine
Damen und Herren wir warten darauf dass
Katja Mast jetzt beginnt
ist diese Regierung gelungen die
Energieversorgung so sicherzustellen
dass es in diesem Winter aller
Voraussicht nach nicht zu einer
gasmangel Lage kommen wird die Industrie
konnte in den letzten Monaten ja meine
Damen und Herren das ist also live hier
über uns auf der Fraktionsebene und wir
warten jetzt darauf dass Katja Mast das
Wort ergreift die Perle mentarische
Geschäftsführerin der SPD
mit den Mitteln aus dem Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds und Sie sehen es
auch noch an den kamerakollegen wird
noch ein wenig eingerichtet hier aber es
müsste dann gleich losgehen es gab beim
Bürgergeld eine Einigung und die Ampel
Fraktionen werden das jetzt hier
zunächst verkünden
wir stellen dafür staatliche Mittel in
erheblichen Umfang zur Verfügung wir
müssen dafür 200 Milliarden Euro
Neuverschuldung aufnehmen und dennoch
ist es nicht möglich alle Belastungen zu
kompensieren das wird uns als Staat
überfordern
um durch diese Krisen zu kommen brauchen
wir die ganze Gesellschaft
ich will an dieser Stelle den
Sozialpartnern in der Metall- und
Elektroindustrie danken der
Pilotabschluss der IG Metall in
Baden-Württemberg der zentral ist für
die Leitindustrie in unserem Land wird
breit übernommen das betrifft 3,9
Millionen Beschäftigten dieser Abschluss
ist von großer Verantwortung geprägt mit
der zweistufigen entgeltsteigerung
erhalten die Kolleginnen und Kollegen in
den Betrieben eine ordentliche
Lohnsteigerung die tabellenwirksam ist
mit der Steuern und abgabenfreien
inflationsprämie in zwei Branchen in
Höhe von 3000 Euro bleibt die Kaufkraft
stabil durch die lange Laufzeit und die
Möglichkeit tarifbestandteile zu
verschieben oder ausfallen zu lassen
verschafft der Abschluss den Unternehmen
gleichzeitig sehr stabile
Rahmenbedingungen
ich darf das Handelsblatt von gestrigen
Tage zitieren die im dritten
Entlastungspaket der Bundesregierung
enthaltene Möglichkeit das
Sonderzahlungen hat erheblichen Druck
aus den tarifkonflikten genommen
damit verringert sich auch der
Inflationsdruck eine lohnpreisspirale
ist nicht zu erwarten das ermöglicht die
kluge Politik dieser ampelregierung und
das ist in diesen Zeiten ein großes
Verdienst
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage oder
Zwischenbemerkung aus der Fraktion DIE
LINKE
[Applaus]
wir sehen einen spektakulären Rückgang
der Erzeugerpreise im Oktober das gibt
Hoffnung dass wir jetzt den Höhepunkt
der Inflation erreicht haben auch die
Konjunkturaussichten haben sich deutlich
verbessert in den letzten Wochen am
aktuellen Rand im Oktober sehen wir auch
wieder deutlich steigende
Steuereinnahmen
insgesamt bleibt die Situation dennoch
kompliziert wir brauchen nach wie vor
die Solidarität der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ihren Energieverbrauch möglichst
zu reduzieren wir legen als Ampel nach
dem parlamentarischen Verfahren einen
hervorragenden Bundeshaushalt 2023 vor
aber wir müssen weiter arbeiten um
künftig zielgenauere Entlastungen
umzusetzen herzlichen Dank
bevor ich den nächsten Redner Aufrufe
das Wort zu einer Kurzintervention der
Abgeordnete Alexander Ulrich
ja Herr Dr Schäfer sie haben eben das
Tarifergebnis in der metalldete
Industrie angesprochen ich bin IG
Metaller ja es war ein richtig guter
Abschluss das haben unsere Leute gut
hingekriegt aber wir haben trotzdem ein
Problem und darauf wollte ich sie
ansprechen es war ja die Bundesregierung
die festgestellt hat dass man eine
zusätzliche Entlastung vielleicht
bräuchte von 3000 Euro denn diese Zahl
ist ja von der Bundesregierung aufs Feld
geworfen worden und die Tarifpartner
versuchen das jetzt auch umzusetzen nach
der IG BCE was jetzt auch die IG Metall
und ich glaube auch im öffentlichen
Dienst werden wir ähnlich erleben aber
wir müssen ja feststellen dass Millionen
ArbeitnehmerInnen Arbeitnehmern in
diesem Land leider nicht in ein
Tarifbindung fallen und oftmals nicht
deshalb weil sie nicht Mitglied einer
Gewerkschaft sind und deshalb was sagen
sie denn der Bäckerei Verkäuferin was
sagen sie denn der Arzthelferin oder
anderen Arbeitnehmer die auch bei der
corona-prämie ausgegangen sind dass sie
auch jetzt wahrscheinlich von diesen
3000 € nicht bekommen werden weil
Arbeitgeber das nicht zahlen werden
glauben Sie nicht das sinnvoll wäre zu
einer Lösung zu kommen dass alle
Arbeitnehmer in diesem Land von einer
Pauschale berücksichtigt werden können
das müssen die Bundesregierung hier
nicht noch weitere Gesetze und
Entlastungen auf den Weg bringen
Herr Dr Schäfer möchten die Antworten
nun
die Bundesregierung und die Koalition
haben wir sehr umfängliche Entlastungen
für die gesamte Bevölkerung beschlossen
auch für den Teil der leider nicht in
den Genuss jetzt von so einer
inflationsprämie kommt wir hatten die
Einmalzahlung im September wir haben
eine große steuertarifreform die jetzt
zum ersten Januar greifen wird mit einer
deutlichen Erhöhung des Grundfreibetrags
Kollege Meyer hat die Rekord Erhöhung
beim Kindergeld erwähnt also eine solche
umfassende
steuerliche Erleichterung hat in der
Geschichte des Landes noch nicht gegeben
und die wird bei allen Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern ankommen und ich wünsche
natürlich möglichst vielen auch eine
inflationsprämie zu erhalten und da
müssen die Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit
ihren Arbeitgebern sprechen ich hoffe
dass die die Chancen die jetzt da sind
entsprechend nutzen
ja und jetzt geht es weiter hier in der
normalen Debatte nämlich mit dem Redner
der CSU Sebastian Brehm er ist für die
Union Mitglied im Finanzausschuss liebe
Frau Präsidentin Liebe Finanzminister
Lindner liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Herr Lindner sie stellen ihren Haushalt
unter die Überschrift Weichenstellung
für eine höhere Resilienz der
öffentlichen Finanzen
tatsächlich sind sie aber die Regierung
mit der höchsten Schuldenaufnahme
innerhalb eines Jahres seit Bestehen der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland mit über
545 Milliarden Euro liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
200 Milliarden Sondervermögen
doppelwumms Abwehrschirm aber genau
definiert ist noch gar nichts und warum
das so lange gedauert hat ist weil sie
erst mit der gasumlage rumgemacht haben
und dann festzustellen dass unser
Vorschlag mit der gaspreisbremse der
richtige Vorschlag ist liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr
richtig aber Sie müssen es auch mit der
notwendigen Geschwindigkeit auf die
Schiene bringen und nicht wie jetzt
einfach warten und abwarten und zögern
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen 60
Milliarden Neuverschuldung aus einem
nicht verfassungsgemäßen nachtragshaus
seit 2021 zumindest aus unserer Sicht
wir prüfen das gerade vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht
140 Milliarden Minus im laufenden
Haushalt 2022 und 65
45,6 Milliarden Minus im Haushalt 2023
ohne unter dem Strich Einsparungen
vorzun hallo liebe Kollegen Kollegen mit
ihrer Politik kommt es zu einer
Verzehnfachung zu einer Verzehnfachung
der Zinslasten für die kommenden Jahre
auf über 40 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr sie
nehmen damit den künftigen Spielraum
jeglichen Handlungsspielraum der
künftigen Haushalte Handlungsspielraum
für notwendige Investitionen
Handlungsspielraum für weitere
Entlastung der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Handlungsspielraum für die von ihnen
immer wieder gewenden und gepriesenen
notwendigen Steuersenkungen her Kollege
Lindner und das Gegenteil ist der Fall
keine Steuerentlastung in 2022 sondern
die kalte Progression wird erst ab 2023
ausgeglichen
und weil sie gerade in ihrer Rede gesagt
haben sie sind gegensteuererhöhungen sie
planen gerade eine übergewinnsteuer mit
dem Jahressteuergesetz 2022 und sie
erhöhen drastisch die Erbschaft und
Schenkungssteuer ebenfalls im selben
Gesetz liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
also sagen sie die Wahrheit die FDP ist
die
steuererhöhungspartei in dieser
Regierung geworden sie missbrauchen
damit das Vertrauen der Menschen die Tag
für Tag zur Arbeit gehen fleißig sind
sich was ersparen und auch der nächsten
Generation weitergeben wollen und sie
haben vorhin gesagt erhalten es muss das
erhalten bleiben und auch an die nächste
Generation weitergegeben werden also
hoffe ich auf sie im Rahmen des
Jahressteuergesetzes 2022 dass diese
unsägliche Erhöhung der Erbschaft und
Schenkungsteuer noch rausgenommen wird
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und sie
schaffen mit diesem Haushalt
und sie schaffen mit diesem Haushalt mit
dem Bürgergeld
Leistungsanreize ab
Deutschland verdient motivierte
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer sie
demotivieren sie Tag für Tag das ist
respektlos gegen den Arbeitnehmern und
Arbeitnehmer die früh zu Arbeit gehen
und arbeiten das hat nichts mehr mit der
Grundidee der sozialen Marktwirtschaft
in Deutschland zu tun nur mit Wachstum
und motivierten Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmern kommen wir aus der Krise
sie verhindern mit diesen Bürgergeld
Wachstum Motivation der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und deswegen
werden wir das nicht unterstützen
und sie machen die Menschen jeden Tag
Stück für Stück ärmer in unserem Land
denn mit ihren 545 Milliarden Euro
Schulden heizen Sie die Inflation erst
noch richtig an wir haben die höchsten
Steuereinnahmen seit Bestehen der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland Tendenz
steigend und sie schaffen es nicht mit
den hohen Steuereinnahmen auszukommen
und die notwendigen Finanzierungen zu
machen der Bundesrechnungshof hat ein
vernichtendes Urteil über ihren Haushalt
gemacht und auch davon gesprochen dass
er gegen die Verfassungsmäßigkeit des
Grundsatzes der Jährlichkeit und auch
mit diesen Sondervermögen sei mal die
Intransparenz erhöht wird liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese maximale
Intransparenz die Sie vornehmen
führt dazu dass sie die Kontrolle über
die Staatsfinanzen gänzlich verloren
haben liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
diese Eindruck wird auch bestärkt in
allen Ausschusssitzungen wenn wir Fragen
stellen sie machen hier eine
intransparente bewusst verdeckende
Politik wir brauchen wettbewerbsfähige
Unternehmen auch das erwarten wir von
Ihnen Herr Lindner dass sie endlich die
notwendigen Steuerreformen für die
Unternehmen auf den Weg bringen wir
haben genug Einsparungsvorschläge im
Rahmen der Haushaltsberatungen gemacht
wir hätten die neue Verschuldung auch
drücken können sie haben unsere Anträge
auf Einsparung komplett abgelehnt
deswegen werden wir selbstverständlich
diesen Haushalt auch ablehnen müssen
herzlichen Dank
Sebastian breh mit einer Feststellung
die nicht verwundert stammte doch von
der cdu/csu-fraktion
sind nicht gestattet ich bitte das zu
berücksichtigen
[Applaus]
jetzt haben wir den nächsten Redner so
kleiner Hinweis an Christian Lindner und
der nächste Redner hier in der Debatte
zum Haushalt
2023 ist Zorn von der SPD ist mit dem
finanzausschussminister Christian
Lindner ich kann sie absolut verstehen
ich weiß Zwischenrufe sind hier nicht
gestattet aber das ist dann doch
schwierig hier zuzuhören ohne dann
tatsächlich zuzurufen Herr Kollege
Bremen ich schätze sie sehr aber die
Rede sollten sich noch mal im Nachhinein
anschauen und dann machen wir meinen
Fakten checken da werden Sie feststellen
da waren viele Unwahrheiten die sie
heute erzählt haben und das hätte ich
von ihm persönlich niemals gedacht
ehrlich gesagt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ihr Leben zweifelsfrei in einer
der schwierigsten zeitgründung der
Bundesrepublik der russische
Angriffskrieg und die multiple Krisen
stellen uns alle vor gewaltigen
Herausforderungen viele Menschen sind
verunsichert und das zurecht und was sie
von der Politik erwarten ist dass wir
Sicherheit und Zuversicht ausstrahlen
und
12 Ampelkoalition haben ein Versprechen
abgegeben und der Bundeskanzler hat das
immer mit dem Satz you never walk alone
festgehalten und oft davon gesprochen
dass wir uns unterhaken müssen manch
einer hat das vielleicht nicht
verstanden viele Abgeordnete der
Unionsfraktion haben das belächelten
kritisiert aber was steckt eigentlich
hinter diesem Satz hinter diesem Satz
steckt das Versprechen dass wir jetzt in
der Krise kein Mensch zurücklassen
wollen dass wir jetzt in der Krise dafür
sorgen wollen dass wir alle mitnehmen
und dass wir solidarisch durch die Krise
kommen und dafür steht auch diese
Ampelkoalition und nein das sind keine
Fragen jetzt komme ich dazu bei liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Haushaltsdebatte ist dann auch die
Stunde der Wahrheit das zeigt sich
nämlich ob das was die Bundesregierung
das was die Ampelkoalition sagt ob das
sich tatsächlich auch im Haushalt
wiederfindet und der Bundeshaushalt 23
ist sehr gelungen uns ist etwas gelungen
was gar nicht so einfach ist nämlich ein
trilemma aufzulösen auf der einen Seite
zwischen jetzt Zusammenhalt und
Unterstützung für die Menschen für die
sozialen Einrichtungen für die
Wirtschaft zu leisten zeitgleich aber
auch in die Transformation zu
investieren in die Zukunft zu
investieren und nicht zuletzt auch
haushaltspolitisch vernünftig hier zu
handeln so ein trilemma aufzulösen war
keine einfache Leistung deswegen mein
Dank gilt dann den Bundesfinanzminister
für einen sehr guten Haushaltsentwurf
der noch parlamentarisch
weiterentwickelt wurde vielen Dank
nochmal die Kollegen im
Haushaltsausschuss
und um auch zu zeigen dass es keine
Phrasen sind wir sagen wir stärken den
Zusammenhalt und sorgen für mehr
Gerechtigkeit und da gibt es drei
Beispiele wo das recht deutlich wird wie
wir das machen die entlastungspakete die
wir beschlossen haben sind konkret im
Haushalt
ethetisiert worden wir haben sowas für
den Heizkostenzuschuss die
energiepauschale das Wohngeld plus viele
Maßnahmen die wir beschlossen haben
finden sich im Haushalt wieder und sind
dort transparent zu finden das zweite
Thema das Thema der zufallsinne wir
haben heute morgen auch darüber
gesprochen wir haben gesagt dass jetzt
in der Krise ist es auch wichtig die
zufallsgewinne die auf dem Strommarkt
entstehen abzuschöpfen das ist das was
wir noch machen werden aber liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es gibt auch
zufallsgewinne die beim Start entstehen
aufgrund der hohen Inflation haben wir
hohe Steuereinnahmen und deswegen war es
uns sehr wichtig als Ampelkoalition mit
dem Inflationsausgleich gesetzt dafür zu
sorgen dass wir den Abbau der kalten
Profession weitervereintreiben und die
Mindereinnahmen von 18 Milliarden Euro
zurück an die Menschen das ist das sind
spürbare Unterstützungen wo viele
Menschen das deutlich führen werden und
dafür steht diese Ampelkoalition
letzter Punkt der auch noch mal zeigt
wie wir für mehr Gerechtigkeit und für
mehr Zusammenhalt sorgen wollen ist das
Thema der Bekämpfung von
Steuervermeidung und Geldwäsche denn das
ist sowieso immer sehr schwierig wenn in
einer Gesellschaft bestimmte Menschen
nicht ihren Beitrag leisten wollen oder
Geldwäsche stattfindet aber insbesondere
in Krisenzeiten ist es eine Frage von
Gerechtigkeit das ist eine Frage von
Zusammenhalt dass wir entschieden gegen
Geldwäsche und Steuervermeidung vorgehen
und deswegen haben wir den Etat des
Zolls erhöht und dafür gesorgt dass wir
jetzt bei der IT-Ausstattung viel
progressiver viel besser arbeiten können
deswegen erhöhen wir auch die Stellen
beim Zoll und bei der Final intelligence
United das ist wofür diese
Ampelkoalition steht und das ist unsere
Vorstellung von mehrgerechtigkeit auch
in der Steuerpolitik liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Ampelkoalition und die Bundesregierung
weiß in welche Zeiten wir uns befinden
das Versprechen was wir abgegeben haben
das gilt wir werden jetzt in der Krise
die Menschen nicht alleine lassen wir
werden alles Mögliche tun um die
Menschen zu unterstützen um soziale
Einrichtungen zu unterstützen um die
Unternehmen zu unterstützen ich würde
mir das auch von den verschiedenen
Fraktionen hier im Hause wünschen
zumindest zu von denen die dazu in der
Lage sind dazu zähle ich die Fraktion
Die Linke und die Unionsfraktion
arbeiten sie konstruktiv mit anstatt
hier immer wieder zu polymisieren vielen
lieben Dank Frau Präsidentin
ja der Appell von einem Sound von der
SPD der nächste Redner ist Robert farle
er ist fraktionslos am 7 September 22
aus der afd-fraktion ausgeschieden wie
bereits dann auch vier andere Joana
Cottage haben es mitbekommen ist gerade
diese Woche gegangen es gibt
mittlerweile sechs fraktionsvor
fraktionslose Mitglieder hier im Hohen
Hause robertal jetzt ist einer davon
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Inflation im zweistelligen Bereich
schrumpfende Wirtschaft
astronomische Energiekosten mit
pleitewellen und Arbeitsplatz
Vernichtung fortlaufende Massen
Einwanderung in die Sozialsysteme
inflationsgetrieben
rekordsteuereinnahmen bei gleichzeitiger
Rekordneuverschuldung von ca 200
Milliarden Euro doppelrums und siehe
Finanzminister Lindner behaupten allen
Ernstes die Schuldenbremse werden
eingehalten ihr Bundeshaushalt
verschleiert doch nur die katastrophale
Situation
unserer Staatsfinanzen wofür geben sie
das Geld aus dass sie überhaupt nicht
haben ca 65 Milliarden Euro werden ans
Ausland verschenkt
seit 2010 wenn sie es nicht glauben
lesen Sie mal vom Kieler
Forschungsinstitut nach seit 2010 haben
sich die Zahlungen an die EU von 18 auf
33 Milliarden Euro erhöht das ist
doppelt so viel wie für Bildung und
Forschung mehr als 10 Milliarden Euro
kostet die Vollversorgung von 600.000
Ukrainern in unserem Land für das
leistungslose Bürgergeld sind 24
Milliarden Euro eingeplant 200
Milliarden energiepreisbremse könnte man
sparen wenn die intakte Pipeline von
Nord Stream 2 für günstiges russisches
Gas geöffnet würde weitere 6,5
Milliarden Euro für die
flüssigkeitsterminals sind dann
ebenfalls unnötig 10.000 neue
Mitarbeiter für die Ministerien sollen
den Berliner Wasserkopf aufblähen die
nicht zu vergessenen und 777 Millionen
Euro für das exorbitant teure Kanzleramt
und noch Präsenz zur notwendig die 100
Milliarden Euro für die Ertüchtigung
unserer Bundeswehr sind wieso wollen sie
Kampfjets und Hubschrauber in den USA
einkaufen und keinerlei
Kompensationsgeschäfte zur Bedingung
machen deutsche Unternehmen sollen nicht
einmal bei Wartungen Instandhaltung
berücksichtigt werden sie finanzieren
damit den Aufschwung in den USA mit
enormen Schulden für kommende
Generationen enteignen inflationär
deutsche damit in den USA Wertschöpfung
Innovation und Steuereinnahmen sprudeln
sie zerstören unsere eigene
Wirtschaftskraft und unseren Mittelstand
die Industrialisierung und ersetzen die
gasabhängigkeit von Russland durch die
LG Abhängigkeit von teurem Gas aus den
USA machen Sie Schluss damit und kümmern
Sie sich mal um die deutschen Interessen
in Deutschland vielen Dank meine Damen
und Herren
[Applaus]
es folgt für Bündnis 90 die Grünen die
Kollegin Jamila Schäfer
Jamila Schäfer ist im Haushaltsausschuss
und Vorsitzende des
bundesfinanzierungsgremiums
Haushaltsausschuss habe ich in den
letzten Wochen mit vielen Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern und Verbänden über die
konkrete Ausgestaltung dieses
Bundeshaushalts gesprochen und das zeigt
dass die Frage wie das Geld in diesem
Krisen ausgegeben wird eine relevantere
ist denn je diese Haushalt der wird
längst als wichtiges politisches
Instrument verstanden und dass wir
dieses Verständnis gemeinsam geschaffen
haben das können wir als wichtigen
Erfolg verbuchen doch wir haben auch
noch was anderes Geschäfte in diesem
parlamentarischen Haushaltsverhandlungen
wir haben uns dem Regierungsentwurf mit
sehr großen Ehrgeiz angenommen und
gerade in diesen Zeiten in denen unsere
Demokratie von allen Seiten angegriffen
wird macht es mich stolz dass dieses
Parlament so stark ist in der
demokratischen Willensbildung und auch
klare Entscheidungen trifft ich danke
allen Kolleginnen und Kollegen im
Haushaltsausschuss für die konstruktive
Zusammenarbeit gemeinsam haben wir den
Entwurf der Bundesregierung ein ganzes
Stück besser gemacht
mit diesem Bundeshaushalt setzen wir dem
russischen Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
und den folgenden humanitären Krisen
etwas entgegen zwei Milliarden gegen
Autokraten eine Milliarde mehr als
vorgesehen für eine wertegeleitete
Außenpolitik und eine Milliarde mehr für
eine solidarische und gerechte
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit ja dass ihnen
das nicht passt das weiß ich schon so
schaffen wir Handlungsfähigkeit in
globalen Krisen und setzen ein klares
Signal gegen Putin und das Regime und
ihre Helfershelfer wir unterstützen die
mutigen Menschen in der Ukraine und im
Iran und wir sorgen dafür dass die
Ärmsten der Armen nicht die
Leidtragenden dieses krises dieses
Krieges sind
wir stehen im Haushaltsausschuss immer
wieder vor der Herausforderung jetzt mit
Krisen umzugehen vor denen eigentlich
vor Jahrzehnten schon gewarnt wurde und
verantwortungsbewusste Politik muss
Krisen erkennen und auffangen bevor sie
über uns hereinbrechen dass wir diese
wirksame Krisenprävention in den letzten
Jahren oft nicht hinbekommen haben daran
hat leider auch die Union einen größeren
Anteil und deswegen würde ich Ihnen da
auch an manchen Stellen zu etwas mehr
demutraten
[Applaus]
sie lernen daraus und machen es heute
besser aber ein aktuelles Beispiel was
wir jetzt auch gerade schon besprochen
haben zeigt ja dass das noch nicht der
Fall ist mit dem Wirtschafts- und
stabilisierungs vornehmen wir im
Rekordtempo jetzt 200 Milliarden Euro
auf und das ist auch dringend notwendig
um die Menschen und Unternehmen zu
entlasten und um Ihnen in diesen
sicheren Zeiten Stabilität zu geben und
das machen wir auch um die fossile
Abhängigkeit abzupuffern die sie mit
verursacht haben doch was machen Sie sie
leben in der Leute Aufladen des WSF von
umfänglich ab und sie kritisieren die
schnellen Hilfen ohne einen konkreten
Gegenvorschlag zu leisten
und was sagt uns das wenn es darauf
ankommt sind sie nämlich nicht bereit
den vielen Familien den
Alleinerziehenden Mittelstand oder dem
Handwerk zu helfen wenn es darauf
ankommt dann kommt von ihnen
parteipolitische Kritik aber keine
Konstruktivität in der Krise schlecht
gespart ist für unsere Wirtschaft
genauso schlecht und deswegen brauchen
wir Investitionen in unsere
Widerstandsfähigkeit die brauchen wir
auch weil sie die Versäumnisse der
Vergangenheit nicht bewältigen konnten
und deswegen leisten wir sie auch
was wir jetzt brauchen ist eine Politik
die die Zukunft im Blick hat die bei der
Eindämmung der bestehenden Krisen keine
neuen schafft ich finde es gut dass wir
mit diesem vorliegenden Haushalt einen
wichtigen Schritt in diese Richtung
gehen vielen herzlichen Dank
der Bundestag debattiert immer noch über
den Einzelplan 028 Finanzen und
Bundesrechnungshof das ist quasi eine
Diskussion über den gesamten Haushalt
traditionell und Ingeborg Grässle von
der CDU CSU hat jetzt das Wort
das nicht nur die Regierung der
Finanzminister sondern auch die
Koalitionsfraktionen überfordert sind
ich glaube heute morgen haben wir das
gesehen alle sind gleichmäßig
überfordert die einen flüchten sich Herr
Minister in die Dampfplauderei die
anderen in die Phrasendrescherei die
wiederum
die Weihrauch fast Schwenker die
weihrauchschwenker sind heute auch
wieder unterwegs und Herr Kollege Rudolf
ich bin ja auch katholisch aber bitte
ich finde wir sind es in sehr schuldig
dass wir doch ernsthaft mit den Dingen
umgehen und von ihnen kam kein einziger
Vorstoß über die Frage was machen wir
denn mit diesen Rekordschulden die sie
zurzeit aufhäufen wir erwarten Antworten
und haben Bundesfinanzminister von ihnen
wären Konsolidierungsbemühungen doch
angezeigt wir müssen diesen Schuldenberg
doch zusammen abräumen wir wollen dass
dieser Schuldenberg abgeräumt wird wenn
die Leute wollen das auch weil alle
wissen alle wissen dass sie diese
Schulden ja bezahlen müssen die lösen
sich ja nicht in Luft auf sondern das
sind Steuern von morgen das wissen alle
und das wissen auch alle dass jede
Wohltat die verteilt wird aus dem
steuersäge kommt aus dem bereits
erwirtschafteten kommt so ich möchte auf
den Bundesrechnungshof zurückkommen
dessen Haushalt wir ja auch heute
beraten und möchte mich sehr herzlich
bedanken Bundesrechnungshof für die
Arbeit für die Analysen ohne die wir die
Regierung nicht kontrollieren könnten
das muss man wirklich ganz ganz offen
feststellen und das ist ein Umstand der
mich schon beschäftigt weil das
Reporting der Regierung die
Berichterstattung der Regierung die
Rechenschaftspflicht so ausgelegt ist
dass wir der Regierung Herr Minister
leider nichts glauben können warum haben
wir eine Regierung der wir nichts
glauben können das ist ein Umstand der
mich wirklich beschäftigt und ich halte
es für dringend geboten dass dieses
Parlament sich Gedanken macht wie wir
die Informationsbasis verbreitern dass
wir uns selber einen besseren Eindruck
verschaffen können über das was in den
Programmen passiert ich habe
Änderungsanträge vorgelegt die sie
abgelehnt haben wir haben viele
eindrucksanträge vorgelegt der Kollege
Hasi hat hat seine ganze Rede damit
bestritten unsere Änderungsanträge
vorzustellen sie wollten diese
Änderungsanträge nicht akzeptieren warum
nicht es ist Standard in Europa in der
europäischen Verwaltung
Leistungsbilanz und Management Bilanzen
Standard hier kontrollieren wir mit
Mitteln der Vergangenheit das heißt wir
kontrollieren gar nicht wir müssen
unsere eigene kontrollbasis verbessern
nur dann würden wir es übrigens auch
schaffen wirklich einen eine Zeitenwende
auch bei den Finanzen hinzukriegen die
Finanzlage muss sie doch mindestens
genauso umtreiben wie uns weil sie ja so
auch in den kommenden Jahren gar nicht
weitermachen können also wer heute im
Haushaltsausschuss war und lieber
Kollege kindlich war eigentlich immer da
ich bin auch immer da das war ein
erschreckendes Zeichen von geballter
Ahnungslosigkeit bei der Frage der
Ausgestaltung der gaspreisbremse sie
Bunkern Geld sie Schichten Schuld auf
Schulter Schulden und Schulden auf
Milliarden und Milliarden in der
Hoffnung dass es dann irgendwann mal
reicht wenn sie vielleicht dann doch
wissen wie es gehen kann ich bin
bestürzt darüber ganz ehrlich gestürzt
und das sieht so mitmachen Weihrauch
verschwendend oder den Mist parfümieren
denn die Regierung ihn hinlegt das
beschäftigt mich sehr weil ich glaube
dass man so genau nicht machen kann und
auch nicht machen sollte
Frau Minister ich möchte meine
verbliebene Zeit dazu verwenden es in
ein paar Fragen zu stellen ich bin schon
besorgt dass es ihnen nicht gelingt
politische Vorstellungen zu konkretieren
im Haushalt im Sommer haben sie uns im
Sommerloch unterhalten mit einem mit der
Idee eines
bundesfinanzkriminalamts das war schön
und im Hinweis dass sich 300 Behörden um
Geldwäsche kümmern und jetzt braucht es
offensichtlich eine 300 eine Behörde die
die Dinge dann angeblich aufs richtige
Gleise bis heute ist die Idee nicht
konkretisiert ich habe viele Fragen
gestellt andere haben viele Fragen
gestellt wir wissen es immer noch nicht
wir wissen nicht wie diese neue Behörde
in die vorhandene Landschaft die
Geldwäsche passt wir haben ja neue
Behörden am Stadt deutsche und
europäische Behörden die glücksregelung
regelungsbehörde die am lade den Epper
europäischer finanzstaatsanwalt wir
haben das zielkriminalamt und
verhandlungsdienst wir haben die
intelligent intelligence also da muss
man es wäre schon schön wenn wir wüssten
was sie sich so vorstellen und wenn sie
es auch uns sagen würden und nicht die
Sache einem influencer überlassen die
letzte Meinungsäußerung aus dem BMF kam
von einem influencer Anfang November
wir haben eine Vielzahl von Meldungen
zum Thema Geldwäsche da gibt es Probleme
wenig Ermittlungen auch da keine
Konkretisierung mich beschäftigt das
weil der Eindruck der Führungslosigkeit
in diesem Sektor herrscht und zu schaden
der Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter die
dieses die ihr Bestes geben und die
Sündenböcke in der Öffentlichkeit sind
und das haben die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter in diesem Bereich nicht
verdient und noch ein Satz zur
Digitalisierung der Verwaltung auch hier
tragen Sie die Frage nur noch einer
bitte
die Verantwortung für die
Standardisierung der Rechenzentren da
gibt es dramatische Rückschritte da darf
jedes Ministerium so tun was es will und
dadurch ja meine Damen und Herren meine
Damen und Herren das hat länger gedauert
als wir alle gedacht haben jetzt hier
also die drei Geschäftsführer
der Ampel die jetzt hier von dannen
gehen wir warten jetzt auf die
Erwiderung durch Friedrich Merz und
Alexander Dobrindt eigentlich soll das
ganze Jahr im Vermittlungsausschuss
verhandelt werden aber natürlich gab es
Arbeitsgruppen vorher die sich
zusammengesetzt haben und jetzt hier
offensichtlich zu dem Kompromiss
beigetragen haben 16 Politiker des
Deutschen Bundestages und 16 Politiker
des Bundesrates davon 14
Ministerpräsidenten nur Brandenburg und
Bayern haben andere Personen benannt
diese 32 werden sich morgen
zusammensetzen und wir haben es ja
gerade von Katja Mast gehört wenn man
sich dann auf den Kompromiss einigt in
diesem Gremium Vermittlungsausschuss von
Bundestag und Bundesrat und dann muss
das Ganze bis 22 Uhr ungefähr fertig
sein am Mittwochabend damit es dann in
die Postfächer gelangt der Abgeordneten
das ist so vorgeschrieben die brauchen
gewisse Vorlaufzeiten bevor das Gesetz
dann hier im deutschen
Bundestag beraten wird erneut beraten
wird dann eben der Kompromiss der dann
in der Vermittlungsausschuss gefunden
sein wird und das ganze wird dann am
Freitag stattfinden ohne Debatte damit
es dann auch noch den Bundesrat erreicht
und jetzt sehen wir hier Friedrich Merz
kommen und auch Alexander Dobrindt und
wollen zuhören was die nun zu diesem
Kompressor sagen und rechts noch Hermann
Gröhe
übrigens mit
einem finanziert werden muss und eine
umfassende Reform des Bafögs meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren all das sind
wichtige Reformen die diese Ampel
bereits umgesetzt hat und die jetzt auch
solide finanziert werden
und die nächste und größte Sozialreform
steht auch noch bevor im
Vermittlungsausschuss wird ja morgen
noch verhandelt werden müssen aber die
Weichen für die bürgergeldreform sind
tatsächlich auch gestellt worden und da
auch das wird natürlich über den
Bundeshaushalt entsprechend erzielt ich
hoffe dass es eine Einigung dann
tatsächlich auch geben wird und wir
haben diese umfassenden Sozialreform
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
auf den Weg bringen können obwohl diese
Bundesregierung kurz nach ihrem
Regierungsantritt und 80 Tage später mit
der Krise des Angriffs von Russland auf
die Ukraine konfrontiert wurde und
obwohl sie krisenbedingte Aufgaben hatte
zum Beispiel die
Energieversorgungssicherheit tatsächlich
auch sicherstellen oder das abfedern der
gestiegenen Energie und
Lebenshaltungskosten und darf das meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren hat
diese Bundesregierung im zügigen Tempo
auf den Tisch gelegt und auch in
entworfen umgesetzt jetzt teilweise
haben wir das auch in den letzten Wochen
schon beschlossen hier im Parlament dazu
haben wir zum Beispiel mehrere
entlastungspakete wie die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger aber auch die Unternehmen auf
den Weg gebracht ich nenne nur
aufzählungsmäßig ein ganz paar die
energiepreispauschale die Erhöhung des
Grundfreibetrages die Verschiebung der
Tarifeckwerte bei der Einkommensteuer
die Kindergelderhöhung auf 250 Euro die
Erhöhung der fernpendlerpauschale die
Erhöhung des Arbeitnehmer Pauschbetrages
der Heizkostenzuschuss das 9 € Ticket
die Erhöhung des Fahrerhaus getragen der
Home Office pauschale gleichzeitig auch
nicht noch die Erhöhung des Unterhalts
Höchstbetrages und des
Kinderfreibetrages und meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren ich könnte
noch viel viel mehr nennen allein im
Bereich der Einnahme Erwartungen dieses
Bundeshaushalts das ist soziale Politik
und das ist Politik für den Zusammenhalt
in unserem Land
und es geht im übrigen auch gar nicht
darum dass man einzelne Maßnahmen dann
tatsächlich umsetzt sondern es geht
immer um Maßnahmen die den Sinn Stärkung
des Zusammenhalts Stärkung der
Solidarität tatsächlich im Sinn haben
der starke hilft dem schwächeren die
Gemeinschaft also der Staat springt dann
ein wenn die Gemeinsamkeit gefragt ist
so haben wir zum Beispiel die
einkommensschwächeren Haushalte mit
zusätzlichen Einmalzahlungen unterstützt
und gleichzeitig werden wir nur
erfolgreich bei der
Energieversorgungssicherheit zum
Beispiel sein wenn jede und jeder
Einzelne jedes Unternehmen jeder Betrieb
aber auch jeder einzelne Haushalt ein
Beitrag zum Energiesparen leistet
gemeinsam kann man viel mehr erreichen
als die Summe einzelner Beiträge
erreichen könnte und umgeben von diesem
zahlreichen Krisen bleiben wir
fokussiert auf das Wesentliche wir
stehen mit diesem Haushalt für soziale
Gerechtigkeit für Klimaschutz und für
Sicherheit und Stabilität in diesem Land
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
und meiner Fraktion waren am besonders
wichtig dass wir zum Beispiel beim
Kindergeld bei den Ausgaben für die
entwicklungspolitische zusammenarbeitet
oder aber auch bei den Unterstützung der
hier ankommenden Menschen aus Flucht und
vertreiben tatsächlich noch mal
zusätzliche Mittel bereitstellen aber
auch die Breite Mitte der
Einkommensbezieher wird entlastet über
die entsprechenden einkommensteuerreform
mit dem
inflationsausgleichsgesetz und ganz
wichtig für meine Fraktion die
zusätzlichen Mitteln für die Erhöhung
der Arbeitsmarkt
Möglichkeiten all das ist wichtig dass
wir tatsächlich Menschen auch wieder in
Arbeit bringen können und Arbeitsplätze
in unserem Land sicher meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren dieser
Haushalt stärkt das Band der Solidarität
in unserer Gesellschaft es ist ein
Haushalt für den Zusammenhalt in unserem
Land vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
ich schließe die Aussprache und wir
kommen zu den Abstimmungen und zwar
zunächst über den Einzelplan 08
Bundesministerium der Finanzen in der
ausschussfassung wer stimmt dafür
dass es die SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und die FDP wer ist dagegen die cduis
CSU die AFD und die Linke Enthaltung
sehe ich nicht damit ist der Einzelplan
08 angenommen wir kommen nun zur
Abstimmung über den Einzelplan 20
Bundesrechnungshof in der
ausschussfassung wer stimmt dafür
das sind alle ich frage noch mal stimmt
jemand dagegen dass sie ich nicht
Enthaltung sehe ich auch nicht dann ist
das einstimmig ist der Einzelplan 20
angenommen
ich rufe nun auf den Einzelplan 65
Bundesministerium für Wohnen
Stadtentwicklung und Bauwesen mit den
Beschlussempfehlungen des Haushalts aus
ja meine Damen und der Einzelplan 25
sieht einen Etat von 7,33 Milliarden
Euro für den Bereich Wohnen
Stadtentwicklung Bauwesen vor das ist
eine Verdopplung im Vergleich zum Jahre
2022 und das liegt unter anderem vor
allen Dingen an der wohngeldreform die
vor kurzem beschlossen wurde bei den
Einnahmen rechnet der Haushaltsausschuss
mit 255
Millionen Euro ein kleines Minus im
Verlauf im Vergleich zum laufenden Jahr
und der erste Redner hier in der Debatte
können wir auch die Aussprache starten
wir stellen Markus Uhl von der CDU zu
ist Mitglied im Haushaltsausschuss und
einen ösus die mittlerweile hier das
Präsidium übernommen hat im Deutschen
Bundestag ruft die Abgeordneten jetzt
auf schnell den Saal zu verlassen und
sich schnell hinzusetzen das ist ja so
üblich wenn die Einzelpläne wechseln
kommen andere Politiker manche gehen so
ist es jetzt auch und damit ein bisschen
Ruhe eingekehrt hat sie jetzt eine Pause
gemacht aber Markus holen jetzt der
erste Gegner CDU Frau Minister wir
beraten heute Finale den Einzelplan 25
des Bundesministeriums für Wohnen statt
Entwicklung und Bauwesen und was ist an
dieser Stelle bereits Anfang September
bei der Beratung des Regierungsentwurfs
gesagt haben das hat sich bewahrheitet
wir haben erhebliche Veränderungen und
Steigerungen im Zuge der
parlamentarischen Beratungen zu
verzeichnen die Ausgaben im Einzelplan
erhöhen sich um 2,3 Milliarden Euro das
entspricht fast der Hälfte des
ursprünglichen Ansatzes und das ist die
relativ gesehen größte Steigerung in
allen Einzelplänen die zusätzlichen
Ausgaben fallen an für Personal und
Material wir haben mit dem Haushalt 23
dann auch endlich Klarheit über die
Struktur des Ressorts die Umsetzungen
und personellen Veränderungen sind
endlich auch im Haushalt nachvollzogen
hat lange gedauert ist aber dann jetzt
auch glücklicherweise erledigt es gibt
erhöhte Mietausgaben für eine neue
Liegenschaft weil die bisherige dringend
sanierungsbedürftig ist aber der
Löwenanteil von mehr als 2,2 Milliarden
Euro mehr entfällt auf das neue Wohngeld
das politische Ziel meine Damen und
Herren das teilen wir aber eines steht
ja heute schon fest viele von denjenigen
dann etwa 2 Millionen Haushalten die
anspruchsberechtigt sein werden werden
erst mal nichts bekommen und sehr sehr
lange warten müssen die wohngeldstellen
in den Kommunen werden der antragslot
eben nicht nachkommen können die
notwendigen Softwareanpassungen brauchen
Zeit das Personal für die Bearbeitung
ist nicht da
der Staat zum ersten nächsten Jahres
wird illusorisch genannt ist hohe ein
Kollaps des wohngeldsystems mehrere
Monate Bearbeitungszeit zum
vorprogrammiert und daher meine Damen
und Herren fällt das Ganze unter die
Kategorie gut gemeint aber schlecht
gemacht
und sie müssen schon aufpassen sie
schüren mit ihrem Vorgehen Erwartungen
die sie dann letztlich leider nicht
erfüllen können und ganz ähnlich ist es
auch beim sozialen Wohnungsbau mit 1,275
Milliarden Euro stellen sie sehr sehr
viel Geld und Schaufenster mit dem Ziel
jährlich 400.000 Wohnungen zu bauen
davon 100.000 Sozialwohnungen doch was
passiert
wir sind heute viel viel weiter von
diesen ambitionierten Zielen entfernt
als die letzten Jahre und wenn es am
Ende die Hälfte der avisierten Wohnungen
wird dann ist das schon viel der Spiegel
schreibt unser Wohnungsmarkt ist außer
Kontrolle wir erleben aktuell massive
Einbrüche beim Wohnungsbau und auch bei
den erteilten Baugenehmigung und
besonders stark meine Damen und Herren
ist der Einbruch bei den
Einfamilienhäusern das hängt mit dem
absehbaren Ende des baukindergeldes
zusammen aber meine Damen und Herren ich
sage Ihnen auch ja da gucken Sie mal was
ihren eigenen berichten drin steht in
dieser Situation ist es wirklich
unredlich sich zusätzlich bei den
Mitteln des baukindergeldes zu bedienen
und gleichzeitig
gleichzeitig haben sie sang und klanglos
den beantragungszeitraum von
ursprünglich Ende nächsten Jahres auf
Ende diesem Jahres vorgezogen und das
führt dazu dass etwa 15 bis 20.000
Familien die fest mit dem Baukindergeld
gerechnet haben jetzt leer ausgehen
meine Damen und Herren das erinnert mich
dann doch schon sehr an ihr unüberlegtes
Handeln bei der überraschenden Ende der
beg-förderung und meines Erachtens sage
ich Ihnen ehrlich ist das ein echter
Skandal
wo bleibt Verlässlichkeit und
Planbarkeit von Politik aber es geht
leider noch weiter die Mittel für die
Städtebauförderung sinken zwei
erfolgreiche Förderprogramme führen sie
eben nicht fort das ist einerseits der
investitionspaktstätten gemeinsam mit
den Ländern und die Förderung der
nationalen Projekte des Städtebaus und
damit lassen sie in einer der
schwierigen Situationen der letzten
Jahrzehnte den Sport das Ehrenamt und
die Kommunen im Stich
und gerade im Bereich der
Städtebauförderung meine Damen und
Herren sehen wir auf der anderen Seite
auch hohe haushaltsliste und ich sage ja
auch was positives bei manchen
Programmen sehen wir leider Gottes dass
nur drei Prozent der bislang
bereitgestellten Mittel abgeschlossen
sind und deshalb unterstützt
ausdrücklich die Initiative die aus dem
Kreisel der Haushälter gekommen ist hier
künftig genauer hinzuschauen und zu
eruieren wo denn die Probleme konkrete
liegen
und da ist aber auch ein absehbar meine
Damen und Herren es ist eben keine Frage
der bereitgestellten Mittel es sind die
grundlegenden die substanziellen
Probleme die gelöst werden müssen wir
müssen einfacher und schneller bauen wir
brauchen weniger Bürokratie statt immer
mehr Geld und das auch noch Schulden
finanziert wir brauchen schnellere wir
brauchen einfachere
Genehmigungsverfahren wir brauchen eine
Harmonisierung der Bauvorschriften und
wir brauchen einfache Regeln für Bauen
im Bestand wir brauchen bessere
Rahmenbedingungen für Investoren für
eine Verbesserung der
abschreibungsregeln steuerliche Anreize
und eine neue Regelung bei der
Grunderwerbsteuer
und ich fasse zusammen meine Damen und
Herren sie stellen viel viel Geld in
Schaufenster die substanziellen probleme
werden nicht gelöst die klare
Prioritätensetzung fehlt und vor allen
Dingen sie schüren Erwartungen die sie
anschließend nicht erfüllen können damit
untergraben sie Verlässlichkeit und
Planbarkeit und damit untergraben sie
auch das Vertrauen der Bürger in die
Politik
Markus Uhl meine Damen und Herren war
das der hier zum Einzelplan 25 der erste
Trainer war wohnen Stadtentwicklung und
Bauwesen und es folgt jetzt für die
Sozialdemokraten Bernhard dahldruck
ersprecher für Kommunalpolitik und auch
im Finanzausschuss
freue mich immer wenn ich sie sehe also
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen werte Frau Ministerin die
Bundesregierung und wir als Parlament
reagieren glaube ich jedenfalls mit
finanziellen Hilfen in unbekanntem
ungekanntem Ausmaß auf die Krisen
unserer Zeit und unsere Maßstab ist
deshalb sich nach den Notwendigkeiten
der Zeit zu richten das heißt Hilfen da
wo es nötig ist und in unserem Sektor
Bauen Sanieren wo es nötig ist Impulse
geben die in die zukunftsweisen unsere
Antwort auf die Sorge vor explodierenden
Energie und Gaspreisen findet sich in
den entlastungspaketen auch in den 200
Milliarden wir lassen dann niemanden
alleine
unser Thema ist dabei das Wohngeld das
jetzt eine Höhe erreicht von der die
groko nur träumen konnte statt 180 Euro
wird es ab Januar im Schnitt 370 Euro
betragen das ist mehr als verdoppelt
dazu eine klimakomponente dazu eine
heizkomponente dazu bereits der zweite
Heizkostenzuschuss mit mehr als 550
Millionen ganz konkrete Hilfe die Zahl
der wohngeld-empfänger wird mehr als
verdreifacht und über 600.000 auf 2
Millionen damit verbunden sind 4,5
Millionen Menschen darunter sind 4,5
Millionen Menschen Alleinerziehende
Rentnerinnen und Rentner Bewohner von
alten und Pflegeeinrichtungen
Arbeitnehmer mit geringen Einkommen so
buchstabieren wir soziale Verantwortung
in der Krise
glauben Sie mir wir nehmen die Sorgen
der Kommunen ernst was die Frage der
Umsetzung des Wohngeldes angeht uns ist
aber wichtig den konkreten Menschen zu
helfen und deshalb ist es meine Bitte an
die Länder und Sie können dabei
mithelfen statten Sie die Kommunen so
auf dass sie ihre Wahlaufgaben auch
tatsächlich wahrnehmen können das ist
die Verantwortung von Ländern die sie
jetzt wahrnehmen müssen und das bedeutet
helfen da wo es nötig ist dazu gehört
auch 1,5 Millionen Euro übrigens zur
Bekämpfung von Wohnungslosigkeit die in
den Haushalt des baumministeriums
übertragen worden sind ich bin der
Ministerin sehr dankbar weil sie eine
Initiative zur Bekämpfung der
Wohnungslosigkeit auf den Weg bringen
will das ist gut so buchstabieren wir
Solidarität in der Krise auch ein
wichtiger Gesichtspunkt nein
helfen wo es nötig ist dazu gehört auch
dass wir die Mittel für den
altersgerechten Umbau von Wohnungen mit
75 Millionen Euro fördern so
buchstabieren wir
Generationengerechtigkeit helfen wo es
nötig ist dazu gehört auch dass soziale
Mietrecht und wir erwarten dass das
Paket zu Stärkung des Mietrechts bald
auch vom Justizminister vorgelegt wird
ein Thema das übrigens auch hier eine
Rolle spielt was zum klimagerechten
Wohnen gehört ist der CO2-Preis in der
Krise kein einfaches Thema deshalb haben
wir die Erhöhung des co2-preises ja auch
ausgesetzt aber nicht ausgesetzt sondern
abgeschafft haben wir die einseitige
Belastung der Mieterinnen und Mieter mit
dem CO2-Preis die wir allein der CDU CSU
zu verdanken haben
ja das soziale Mietrecht ist eine
aktuelle Hilfe bei hohen Mieten und
galoppierenden Energiepreisen die
Ausweitung des bezahlbaren Wohnens ist
eine andere Seite und deshalb bauen wo
es nötig ist wir finden uns nicht damit
ab dass die Zahl der Sozialwohnungen ja
für ja weiter sinkt wir wollen die
45.000 die es um gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt
gibt verdoppeln und deshalb
verdreifachen wir die Mittel für den
sozialen Wohnungsbau bis 2026 auf 14,5
Milliarden und wir werden diese
Investitionen übrigens mit einer
Initiative zur Wiederherstellung des
gemeinnützigen Wohnungsbaus begleiten
baumlos nötig ist dass er schöpft sich
aber nicht nur in der Ausweitung des
sozialen Wohnungsbaus und der Ulli ich
sag mal so ich habe das Baukindergeld
nie kritisiert aber ich habe solche
wirklich wundersamen Wirkungen wie sie
dem zusprechen nie zugesprochen die hat
auch nicht gehabt das können Sie auch
sehr schön nachlesen ich hatte ja nichts
dagegen aber ich will noch mal sagen wir
haben ein Programm für den
klimafreundlichen Neubau und
Wohneigentum Förderung für Familien und
dazu stellen wir eine Milliarde zur
Verfügung um damit Menschen den Traum
vom Eigenheim verwirklichen können und
wir geben neue Impulse für bewährte
Wohnformen beispielsweise die
Genossenschaften deren Gründung und
Bautätigkeit wir stärken allein das sind
3,6 Milliarden Euro für den
Wohnungsneubau und dabei unterstützen
wir auch die Wohnungswirtschaft mit
ihren tausenden von Beschäftigten es ist
glaube ich nicht unser Etat aber es ist
ein Meilenstein dass wir über 13
Milliarden für aus dem klimafond für
klimagerechte Sanierung unseres
Wohnungsbestandes zur Verfügung stellen
und mindestens erwähnt sei auch die
Bauforschung denn Herr Uhl ja wir
brauchen carbonbeton wir brauchen wir
brauchen CO2-freie Zementwerke wir
brauchen eine Holzbau Strategie neue
Dämmmaterialien schnellere Verfahren sie
wollen das wir machen das das ist der
Unterschied den wir jetzt darstellen
müssen und wir halten auch am Ziel der
400.000 Wohnungen fest wir kennen die
niedrigen Zahlen wir wissen um die Ziel
zu hohen bauüberhänge und wir sehen das
geplante Bauvorhaben zu Disposition
stehen diese Krise der Bauwirtschaft
beantworten wir aber nicht mit Rückzug
sondern mit Investitionen erst recht
nicht übrigens mit fremdenfeindlichen
Parolen die wahrscheinlich gleich noch
kommen werden über Zuwanderung die den
Ausbau des Wohnungsmarktes belasten
sondern mit neuen Impulsen für die
Wohnungswirtschaft das ist auch Ausdruck
von Solidarität ich bin dankbar für das
Bündnis für bezahlbaren 187 Vorschlägen
und ich will an dieser Stelle hinweisen
dass sich weiterhin die Städte
Überforderung auf die auf Rekordniveau
verhält das weiterhin die urbanen Räume
an den Klimawandel unterstützen
Sanierung von Sportstätten und so weiter
gefördert werden wir lassen die Kommunen
nicht im Regen stehen wir erwarten dass
die Länder es auch machen also ich sage
folgendes Fazit ziehen in einem Jahr
Kollege sie müssen jetzt wirklich zum
Schluss kommen mache ich jetzt nach
einem Jahr dieses Ministeriums
herzlichen Dank an die Ministerin an die
engagierten Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter wir sind auf dem richtigen
Weg und haben die Weichen richtig
gestellt vielen Dank
das Wort erhält für eine kurze
Intervention dr Jan Marco Luczak
vielen Dank Herr Kollege meine
Zwischenfrage nicht zugelassen deswegen
möchte ich auf diesem Wege noch einmal
darauf zurück ja meine Damen und Herren
und das war also die Pressekonferenzen
zunächst von der Ampel und jetzt also
von der CDU CSU es ging um den
Bürgergeld es hat dort einen Kompromiss
gegeben die Interpretation haben sie
gehört sind durchaus sehr
unterschiedlich morgen kommt das
Bürgergeld in den sogenannten
Vermittlungsausschuss von Bundestag und
Bundesrat und wenn es dann dort geeint
sein sollte dann kann man es wenn es vor
22 Uhr sein wird noch in
Bundestag verabschieden nämlich am
Freitag das wäre insofern wichtig als
das Freitag auch der Bundesrat sitzt der
ist ebenfalls noch mal verabschieden
muss damit die Bürger Geldreform dann
auf ihren Weg gehen kann er strebt das
Ziel ist ja der erste Januar so und wir
sind zurück hier in den
Haushaltsberatungen im Deutschen
Bundestag mittlerweile 25 wohnen
Stadtentwicklung und Bauwesen angekommen
ein Etat von 7,33 Milliarden Euro hat
die Bundesministerin Clara Gallwitz
damit eine Verdopplung des Vorjahres das
liegt vor allen Dingen an der
wohngeldreform und Markus Bühl
hatte eben das Wort jetzt gibt es aber
momentan gerade eine
Kurzintervention und eine Erwiderung
und zwar am Anfang des Jahres im Januar
und nicht erst am Ende des Jahres so wie
es wahrscheinlich sein wird wir erklären
sich das dass sie das völlig ignoriert
haben das ist unverständlich dass sie
das nicht aufgegriffen haben der
Lutscher von der Union hat jetzt hier
noch ganz kurz das Wort gehabt und der
da da war nämlich der letzte Redner der
SPD kann darauf noch erwidern
dass sie es nicht wahrgenommen haben
heißt ja nicht dass wir nicht reagiert
haben
das ist nicht dasselbe wir haben die
Bewilligungszeiträume beispielsweise auf
24 Monate verlängert seine eminent
wichtige Vereinfachung seine eminent
wichtige Vereinbarung wir haben an
verschiedenen Stellen versucht weitere
Vereinfachungen zu machen die wir auch
vom Bundesrat sozusagen diskutiert haben
aber ich will an dieser Stelle auch eins
sagen ich habe es ja gesagt wir wissen
um die Belastung der Kommunen wir wissen
darum aber im Abwägungsprozess sage ich
ihnen ist für uns die Hilfe für die
betroffenen Menschen das wichtigste und
ich habe mich sehr sehr vielen
Betroffenen ja ich habe mir sehr sehr
vielen Betroffenen gesprochen
Amtsleitern Sachbearbeitern und
Dezernenten die sich dieser Aufgabe
tatsächlich auch stellen und ich möchte
gerne dass sie sozusagen nicht einfach
den nicht einfach nicht einfach die
Gelegenheit nutzen auch den Bund zu
zeigen sondern so wie sie es in den
Jahren zuvor in jeder Sitzung gemacht
haben auch daran zu appellieren dass die
Länder ihre Kommunen mit dem
entsprechenden Personal und mit der
entsprechenden Grundfinanzierung
ausstatten das wäre sehr gut ich kann
das ihnen in Nordrhein-Westfalen in
wenigen Sätzen sozusagen detailliert
erläutern das können wir nach der
Sitzung machen vielen Dank ich habe gar
nicht mitgekriegt dass sie die
Zwischenfrage gestellt haben ich hatte
eine ganz andere Gegend
tja sonst hätte er vielleicht die
Zwischenfrage zugelassen aber jetzt geht
es jetzt hier weiter in der Debatte um
den Einzelplan 25 wohnen
Stadtentwicklung und Bauwesen und ich
nehme an und hör mal zu jawohl das
nämlich der von mir schon aufgerufen im
Markus Bühl jetzt für die AFD das Wort
bekommt er ist Mitglied im
haushaltsvorschuss
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
bezahlbares Wohnen war eines der
Hauptthemen im Wahlkampf 2021 von den
Parteien die heute die Vertreter der
Bundesregierung Stellen etwas über ein
Jahr danach ist Bauen und Wohnen so
teuer wie nie die Inflation ist dabei
maßgeblicher Treiber allen voran die
energieverteuerung die Regierung Merkel
und sie die Links grüne Bundesregierung
sind maßgeblich verantwortlich für diese
horrenden Energiekosten
von der co2-bepreisung bis zur geplanten
Abschaltung der letzten Kernkraftwerke
nächstes Jahr sie zeigen ganz klar was
ihnen selbst in Zeiten größter Not
wichtiger ist
gleichzeitig nehmen Sie Abermilliarden
Schulden auf um Hilfspakete zu schnüren
die erst durch ihre Politik nötig
geworden sind was wir brauchen ist eine
fähige Bundesregierung die endlich die
Probleme an der wurzelpackt dann
erübrigen sich auch die von uns selbst
zu zahlenden Hilfspakete
für viele Haushalte in Deutschland ist
wohnen nahezu unbezahlbar geworden
jährlich 400.000 Wohnungen hat diese
Bundesregierung vollmundig am Anfang
ihrer Amtszeit versprochen dieses Jahr
werden es weit unter 300.000 fertig
gestellte Wohnungen sein verfehlter
Ergebnisse sind typisch für ihre
linksgrüne Politik
für einen Wohnungsprojekt hat links gelb
jedoch gegen unsere Anträge und stimmen
die Weichen gestellt der Bundeskanzler
bekommt eine neue 250 Quadratmeter große
Dienstwohnungen in Berlin Mitte es ist
überhaupt nicht zu verstehen warum mit
diesen schwierigen Zeiten mit steigender
Inflation und Energiekrise die Regierung
an einem Erweiterungsbau des
Bundeskanzleramtes festhält der Bau soll
der Bau soll doch jetzigen Stand 777
Millionen Euro kosten und damit hunderte
Millionen Euro mehr als noch im Frühjahr
diesen Jahres bis zur Kostensteigerung
auf eine Milliarde ist es nun nicht mehr
weit zum Vergleich ein süddeutscher
Autohersteller hat vor zwei Jahren eine
hochmoderne digitalisierte Fabrik im
Umfang von 30 Fußballfeldern für ca
730 Millionen Euro in Betrieb genommen
die Bundesregierung hingegen können sich
ein völlig überdimensioniertes Bauwerk
während sie gleichzeitig den Bürgern
Spartipps beim Heizen gibt stoppen Sie
diesen Erweiterungsbau des
Bundeskanzleramtes wir werden im
Haushalt in dieser Form natürlich nicht
zustimmen ich danke für die
Aufmerksamkeit
nächster Redner in dieser Debatte ist
Markus Kurt für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen meine Damen und Herren
dieser Haushalt bietet sowohl kurz-
und ja natürlich ist das eine
Herausforderung verwaltungstechnisch wir
haben aber zum Beispiel mit der
Möglichkeit von
abschlagsvorschusszahlungen zum Beispiel
Instrumente geschaffen wie man die
Auszahlung vereinfachen kann und es ist
jetzt auch Vorbereiter sind auch
Vorbereitungsmöglichkeiten jetzt für die
Kommunen und es bleiben an der eine oder
anderen Stelle wo Kommunen besonders
unter ausgestattet sind natürlich
vielleicht noch hier und dort
Schwierigkeiten aber Herr Uhl soll denn
dann die Konsequenz aus dem ganzen sein
dass man gar nichts macht Herr Uhl ihre
Rede war eine Empfehlung für
ambitionslosigkeit das kann doch nicht
die Antwort in dieser Lage sein
sondern man muss das versuchen es ist
auch ja so dass die Jobcenter ein halbes
Jahr lang auch nicht durch den
vorrangigen Anspruch des wohngelds
prüfen das ist auch ein bisschen holprig
das gebe ich offen zu diese
übergangsmöglichkeit aber die
Alternative wäre auf diesen qualitativ
großen Schritt in diesen
Herausforderungen herausfordernden
Zeiten zu verzichten und das geht
definitiv nicht da haben wir uns
eindeutig als Ampel anders entschieden
und natürlich sind wir auch bei den kurz
bis auch mittelfristigen Elementen
weiterhin dabei diesen Schwerpunkt in
diesem Haushalt geblieben das ist der
soziale Wohnungsbau aber wir blicken
auch weiter in die Zukunft mit zum
Beispiel dem maßgabebeschluss den wir
als Haushälter zum Thema neue
wohngemeinnützigkeit getroffen haben
wollen wir die Voraussetzung dafür
schaffen wollen wir die Voraussetzungen
dafür schaffen dass nicht nur mit Hilfe
des Wohngeldes Mietzahlungen
subventioniert werden denn das ist ja
letztlich was dort passiert sondern dass
im Bestand gewirtschaftet werden kann
mit dem Ziel langfristig qualitativ
hochwertigen Wohnraum bezahlbar zu
halten für die Menschen das sind
qualitatives politikziel des nachhaltig
ist und das werden wir jetzt endlich auf
den Weg bringen
und gleiches gilt beim Bereich Forschung
wo wir noch ebenfalls in einem
maßgabebeschluss deutlich gemacht haben
dass wir in der Entwicklung neuer
Baustoffe holzbaustrategie das werden
wir noch qualifizieren gegenüber dem
Ministerium dass wir dort eine
Weiterentwicklung brauchen wir brauchen
allerdings auch nicht nur Forschung
sondern wir müssen die jetzt schon
vorhandenen Möglichkeiten
serielle Sanierung Einsatz neuer
Baustoffe jetzt auch in der Breite in
die Anwendung bringen die Möglichkeiten
sind da und das ist auch in Zeiten von
Schwierigkeiten das Carbon gestützte
Baustoffe Zement immer teurer werden
dringend notwendig mit Blick auf die
Baukosten
[Applaus]
zum Thema altersgerecht wohnen wo sich
alle drei Berichterstatter im
Haushaltsausschuss einig waren muss ich
gar nicht viel sagen da ist klar dass
wir angesichts der alternden
Gesellschaft hier aufstocken mussten
eigentlich das konnten wir gar nicht
anders machen ich glaube wir hätten
sogar Thorsten Herbst da noch noch mehr
gewollt wir freuen uns nämlich auch dass
dieses Programm sich eines
regenmittelabflusses erfreut und dass da
sehr schnell sehr viel abfließen kann
und
dann will ich noch eingehen zum Schluss
auf das Thema lebenswerte Städte ich
glaube man kann nicht über diesen
Haushalt reden ohne über auch das
Programm der Sanierung kommunaler
Einrichtungen im Bereich Sport Jugend
und Kultur zu reden wir stehen hier
jetzt vor der Phase der Entscheidung der
aktuellen projektscheibe und ich glaube
das ist auch ein wesentlicher Anteil bei
der Unterstützung unserer Kommunen so
etwas Wichtiges wie ihre Sportstätten
die vielfältig aus den 60er 70er-Jahren
des vergangenen Jahrhunderts doch
reparaturbedürftig sind ihnen dabei
unter die Arme zu greifen
und da möchte ich auch noch mal an
dieser Stelle dann dem Bundesrat und der
dann doch häufig vorgetragenen Kritik
durch die Länder auch mal entgegenhalten
und Sie bitten sich diesen Haushalt
insgesamt mehr anzusehen
denn viele
Investitionsmaßnahmen oder Unterstützung
von Investitionen die wir machen die
kommen direkt in Kommunen und der
Landesebene zugute und ich glaube das
sollte man auch mit anerkennen wenn man
an anderer Stelle Kritik gegenüber dem
und äußert und da würde ich mich freuen
einfach wenn diese Anerkennung auch dem
Deutschen Bundestag entgegengebracht
werden würden
und ebenso mit Blick auf die Länder
will ich noch ganz kurz das Thema
Mittelabfluss ansprechen das muss man
als
haushaltsverantwortlicher tun an der
Stelle und wir haben dort mit mehreren
Maßgabe Beschlüssen auch uns das
angesehen und wollen dort mehr Nachdruck
sozusagen hinbringen das mit das Geld
was wir auch Kommunen beispielsweise zur
Verfügung stellen dann auch schließlich
vernünftig im Sinne einer nachhaltigen
lebenswertigen Zukunft im Städtebau
eingesetzt werden kann vielen Dank
Markus kurt war das für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen im Bundestag Karin lay wird nun
für die Linksfraktion sprechen sie hat
sich schon im Vorfeld besonders über die
neue Festlegung der mietenstufen
beschwert diese kritisiert wir werden
jetzt eventuell weitere Details dazu
hören meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren es bräuchte eigentlich 6
Millionen Wohnungen für Haushalte mit
geringem und mittlerem Einkommen
doch leider haben wir gerade mal eine
Millionen Sozialwohnungen das ist ein
historischer Tiefstand und nicht zu
akzeptieren
wir brauchen also eigentlich fünf
Millionen Sozialwohnungen mehr die
Schaffung von Sozialwohnungen muss jetzt
die oberste Priorität aller Neubau
Tätigkeit haben denn mit mehr teuren
Wohnungen ist diesen Menschen nicht
geholfen
doch die Ziele der Bundesregierung
100.000 neue Sozialwohnungen im Jahr zu
schaffen werden grandios verfehlt im
letzten Jahr wurden gerade mal 23.000
neue Sozialwohnungen gebaut und die
Zahlen sind rückläufig wenn wir hier
nicht vorankommen dann erreichen wir die
versprochenen 100.000 Sozialwohnungen
nicht im Jahr sondern bestenfalls in der
Legislatur und das ist nicht akzeptabel
schlimmer noch jedes Jahr fallen mehr
Sozialwohnungen aus der Bindung wie neue
gebaut werden im letzten Jahr gab es
unterm Strich ein Minus von 27.000
Sozialwohnungen weniger wenn das so
weitergeht dann ist der soziale
Wohnungsbau bald Geschichte und das darf
nicht passieren
nun kann man natürlich sagen das ist
alles noch von der alten Regierung
geerbt doch die weichen die sich stellen
reichen eben bei weitem nicht aus mit
einer Verdoppelung oder einer
Verdreifachung der Mittel kann man keine
Vervierfachung des Neubaus erzielen das
ist doch völlig klar und
1,275 Milliarden Euro fragt Dich
ausgegeben im Jahr das ist für die
gesamte Bundesrepublik für den Neubau
von Wohnungen eine lächerlich geringe
Summe
und zweitens muss es darum gehen dieses
permanente Auslaufen der Bindungen
endlich zu verhindern dieses irrsinnige
Prinzip das muss einfach gestoppt werden
es ist doch nicht nachhaltig eine
Sozialwohnung zu finanzieren und nach 15
Jahren fällt sie aus der
preis-bindung und das erreichen wir eben
am besten durch eine neue
wohnungsgemeinnützigkeit denn nur diese
garantiert einmal Sozialwohnung immer
Sozialwohnungen ja wir sind uns da einig
aber weit und breit von diesem Gesetz
keine Spur
ich habe immer gesagt man muss das zu
Beginn der Legislatur machen damit es
eben kein Nischenprodukt bleibt sondern
dass wir jetzt noch in den Wiederaufbau
eines großen gemeinnützigen
wohnungssektors investieren können den
wir in Deutschland noch einmal hatten
aber stattdessen geben wir weiter
fordermittel für private börsennotierten
börsennotierte wohnungskonzerne aus das
ist doch völlig absurd
wir als LINKE wollen die neue
wohnungsgemeinnützigkeit schnell
einführen und wir wollen dort viel Geld
investieren 18 Milliarden schlagen wir
dazu vor im Jahr und sagen Sie bitte
nicht dass dafür kein Geld da ist also
dieses Sondervermögen für Aufrüstung
dass sie hier in Windeseile
durchgewunken haben das wäre im
gemeinnützigen Wohnungsbau deutlich
besser angelegtes Geld gewesen
und es muss auch nicht immer Neubau sein
wir wollen auch in Ankauf von Wohnungen
und in den Umbau des Bestandes
investieren
Parkhäuser zur Genossenschaften
leerstehende Bürogebäude zu
Sozialwohnungen das ist unser Programm
man kann auch die Kommunen darin
unterstützen die massenhaft
privatisierten Wohnungen zurückzukaufen
es wäre das mindeste hier in einen
rekommunalisierungsfonds zu investieren
und dafür bräuchten wir natürlich auch
ein verbessertes Vorkaufsrecht aber
selbst ein Jahr nachdem das Gericht das
bestehende Vorkaufsrecht gekippt hat
weit und breit keine Spur von einem
neuen Gesetz die Kommunen stehen den
Spekulanten jetzt mit leeren Händen
gegenüber ich finde das total
vielen steht zum Thema Mietrecht der
sowieso nicht im Koalitionsvertrag aber
selbst das lässt auf sich warten gerade
jetzt vor diesem Winter wäre ein
bietenstopp und ein besserer
Kündigungsschutz höchste Zeit
das Chaos vom Wohngeld Schleswig wäre
vermeidbar gewesen wenn man unseren
Vorschlag angenommen hätte nämlich die
alten Anträge die bereits bewilligt
waren pauschal und vorläufig vor ein
Jahr zu verlängern damit die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen die jetzt Überstunden
machen müssen und am Wochenende arbeiten
müssen diese Anträge erstmal die neuen
Anträge hätten bearbeiten können das
wäre richtig und gut gewesen
Klimaschutz meine Damen und Herren muss
ohne Mieterhöhung möglich sein deswegen
fordern wir fünf Milliarden Euro um
erstmal bei den energieintensiven
Nachkriegsbauten anzufangen und zu
klimagerechten Städten gehört eben auch
eine gut ausgestattete
städtebauforderung lassen sie uns mehr
Geld in die Begründung von Dächern und
Fassaden in essbare Gärten und in die
Aufforstung der Städte investieren
klimagerechte Städte sind lebenswerte
Städte
kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss Frau
Kollegin
prima zu lebenswerten Städten gehört
eben auch Musik gehören Konzerte
ein Schallschutzprogramm gefordert auch
davon leider keine Spur das Clubsterben
muss verhindert werden dass Monopoly und
das Monopoly müssen beendet werden
vielen Dank
soweit Karin Ley die Sprecherin für
Mieten Bar und Wohnungspolitik hier der
Linksfraktion ist zum Schluss noch mal
auf die Nachtszene eingegangen auch da
guckt man natürlich mit Sorge auf den
kommenden Winter oder der ja schon da
ist Torsten Herbst spricht nun für die
FDP-Fraktion sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren kein Haushaltsentwurf geht und
vor einer durch das Parlament des gilt
auch für den Etat des baumministeriums
und ich bin froh dass es gelungen ist
gemeinsam mit den Partnern in der Ampel
diesen etwa noch deutlich besser zu
machen
und es gab nicht nur einen
aufwuchsfinanziell der natürlich ein
hohem Maße durch das Wohngeld verursacht
wurde sondern wir haben weiterhin an der
höchst investitionsanteile aller
Einzelhaushalte hier im Bundestag ich
bin stolz dass wir zu diesem
rekordinvestitionsvolumen von 71 Monaten
Euro in diesem Bundeshaushalt beitragen
worum geht es uns mit diesem Haushalt
der erste Punkt wir wollen privates
Wohneigentum ermöglichen Wohneigentum
meine Damen und Herren ist der Schlüssel
zu einer stabilen Gesellschaft und es
ist auch der Schlüssel zur Schaffung von
ausreichend Wohneigentum und dem führen
wir uns verpflichtet
und anders als die Linksfraktion immer
behauptet sind auch die Masse der
Vermieter nicht Großkonzerne zwei
Drittel fast zwei Drittel aller
Wohnungen in Deutschland werden durch
private Kleinvermieter zur Verfügung
gestellt die haben ein zwei Wohnungen
und ohne die an Engagement ohne die an
Investitionen Sie es richtig düster am
Wohnungsmarkt aus
und deshalb ist das auch richtig dass
wir gesagt haben wir beenden das wenig
zielgerichtete baukindergelten wir
starten ein neues Neubau Förderprogramm
damit mehr privat Wohnungseigentum
schaffen werden kann
und es ist auch richtig dass wir mehr
Mittel für das altersgerechte umbauen
mobilisiert haben der Kollege kurz hat
es schon angesprochen denn wer länger in
den eigenen vier Wänden wohnen kann das
ist nicht nur eine wohnungspolitische
Dimension das hat auch eine
gesellschaftspolitische und
sozialpolitische Dimension wir wollen
dass Menschen in den eigenverbänden in
Würde älter werden können
der zweite Punkt und ich glaube der ist
jenseits des Geldes eine große
Herausforderung ja wir müssen bauen
bezahlbarer und schneller machen und
gerade jetzt wo wir alle merken dass der
Kostendruck zunimmt das heißt wir müssen
noch mal uns Standards anschauen
gesetzliche Vorschriften Genehmigung und
auch den Weg frei machen das neue
bautechnologien schneller zur Anwendung
kommen ich setze da auch auf die
Ergebnisse des Bundes bezahlbare
Wohnraum ich glaube zusammen mit dem
Bauministerium werden wir auch
Fortschritte erreichen da bin ich mir
sicher
wir wollen auch dafür sorgen dass wir
insgesamt beim Bauen mehr Innovationen
erreichen das Tempo ist dort zu langsam
und wenn ich nur einige Stichworte nenne
carbonbeton sehr jelles bauen Holzbau
neue Dämmstoffe wir müssen schneller zur
praktischen Anwendung zu kommen um
a-material zu sparen auch CO2-Emissionen
bei Bau und im Betrieb zu senken das ist
nicht nur eine ökologische
Herausforderung sondern auch eine
ökonomische Notwendigkeit wenn wir
weniger Energie verbrauchen macht sich
das auch im Geldbeutel bemerkbar und
deshalb bin ich froh dass wir mehr
Mittel für die Bauforschung mobilisiert
haben
wenn wir uns im Land umschauen und zu
Hause in unseren Wahlkreisen das sehen
wir dass wir viele öffentliche Gebäude
haben die sehr energieintensiv sind das
sind Schwimmhallen Sportstätten auch
denkmalgeschützte Museen wo man oft die
Umgebung mitteilt und deshalb ist es so
wichtig dass wir auch da herangehen den
Energieverbrauch bei öffentlichen
Gebäuden zu senken und deshalb haben wir
eine neue Förderrunde zur Sanierung
kommunaler Einrichtung Sportstätten
erreicht da auch ein herzliches
Dankeschön an Koalitionspartner
und wir nehmen auch zur Kenntnis meine
Damen und Herren dass wir nicht nur
Wohnungsbaupolitik aus dem Blickwinkel
der Ballungsräume machen denn es gibt
nicht nur den Prenzlauer Berg es gibt
auch die Region und Prenzlau die
Uckermark und dort sind die
Herausforderung ganz anders denn auf der
einen Seite sehen wir wohnungsnoten auf
der anderen Seite wohnungslehr stand
deshalb ist es für uns ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir auch die Lebensqualität in
ländlichen Region erhalten und dass wir
Mobilität bezahlbar machen um nicht noch
mehr Druck auf die Metropolen zu
erzeugen
zum Abschluss noch ein Wort zur Union
das ist ja schon sehr interessant wenn
man die ersten reden heute hört dann
kritisieren die Haushaltspolitiker Union
dass wir viel zu viel Geld ausgeben wenn
wir die Reden der Fachpolitiker der
Union hören wird immer kritisiert dass
wir zu wenig Geld ausgeben das heißt sie
fordern mehr Ausgaben ohne zu sagen wie
diese Ausgaben gedeckt werden dass ein
Widerspruch den sollten Sie mal intern
versuchen zu klären
und im Gegensatz zu ihnen kann ich sagen
bei uns als Ampelkoalition ist der Etat
des Bauministeriums in hervorragenden
und wir haben Geld mit dem wir arbeiten
können wir können bauen beschleunigen
wohnen bezahlbar halten privates
Wohneigentum fördern das ist der
Unterschied zur Union meine Damen und
Herren
Thorsten Herbst hat hier noch mal auf
die Unterschiede der Fraktionen
hingewiesen wobei wir die ja auch gerade
in der Bau- und Wohnungspolitik auch in
der Debatte mitkriegen und genau
erläutern kann das jetzt Michael
Breilmann für die Unionsfraktion
Kollegen wenn ich jetzt hier so die
Lobeshymnen höre der Koalitionäre zu den
Hilfen in dieser Energiekrise dann kann
ich dem relativ einfach entgegnen und
das ist nicht mein Urteil sondern das
ist der Urteil von der
Wohnungswirtschaft und auch der
kommunalen Familie es ist viel zu spät
und es ist alles viel zu kompliziert
und wir haben es in der letzten Debatte
auch schon angesprochen die Schonzeit
für diese Regierung die ist längst
vorbei dieser Etat 2023 der kann sich
nicht mehr hinter Zuständigkeiten der
Vorgängerregierung verstecken und es ist
gerade schon deutlich geworden ja der
Baubereich der steckt in einer tiefen
Krise und der finde ich es nicht gut
wenn in der Öffentlichkeit von Frau
Ministerin galwitz Nachholbedarf
eingeräumt wird aber die Situation
Vorgängerregierung versucht wird in die
Schuhe zu schieben ich kann den wirklich
nur entgegnen wenn die unionsgeführten
Bundesregierung in den letzten Jahren
nicht so wirtschaftlich gut geh
haushaltet hätten dann könnten Sie hier
Ihre teuren Versprechung und ihre
schaufensterpolitik sich gar nicht
leisten so sieht's aus
und sie liefen liefern mit ihrer Politik
auch keine wirksamen Antworten zu Lösung
der schwerwiegenden
Probleme wenn ich das hier alles so höre
und sehe dann handeln sie eher nach dem
Motto wir schaffen zwar keine 300 bis
400.000 neue Wohnungen jährlich sind
aber in der Lage mit unserer Politik
jedes Jahr mindestens drei bis 400.000
Menschen in diesem Land zu verunsichern
mit großem haben sie kürzlich ein
Bündnis bezahlbarer Wohnraum im
Kanzleramt zelebriert und ein Katalog
mit 187 Einzelmaßnahmen gegen
Deutschlands Wohnungskrise vorgelegt das
ist aber alles auf Basis eines
minimalkonsensors vieler Gruppen erfolgt
und wir finden eigentlich kaum neue
handlungs
und wir haben sowieso kein Erkenntnis
sondern wir haben ein Umsetzungsproblem
nicht nur bis zur formalen Genehmigung
eines Bauantrages vergeht immer mehr
Zeit es dauert auch immer länger bis ein
genehmigtes Projekt fertig wird gut
sechs Wochen vor dem Beginn des neuen
Jahres braucht es dringend Klarheit über
neue förderkulisten und Konsequenz muss
auch sein die geplanten Bauvorschriften
und alles was dem Bau 2023 verteuert
einem klaren Realitätscheck zu
unterziehen das Dickicht der
Bauvorschriften es muss dringend
gelichtet werden
und ich frage mich auch ich frage mich
auch welchen Stellenwert haben
eigentlich die Kommunen bei dieser
Koalition es ist ja gerade schon
deutlich geworden bei der SPD wir
schaffen zusätzliche Arbeitsaufgaben wir
schaffen zusätzlichen Arbeitsanfall und
für neue Stellen sollen dann Kommunen
und Länder besorgen das ist eine
Arbeitsaufteilung die können wir nicht
akzeptieren
und so finden sich in diesem Metall im
Vergleich zum letzten Haushalt viele
viele kommunalrelevante Minderausgaben